Guys, oh, this is not good.
Okay, wait, okay, okay, we're okay, okay, we're okay, I was like, wait, why am I not moving, oh no, oh no, wait, what is this game even called, it's called B1, it's called B1, okay, I was like, what the fuck is this game called, okay, B1, okay, guys, yeah,
so, I was like, yeah!
And I was like, oh no, wait, shader compilation in progress, what do you mean?
Alright, so yes, the reason why I did not start stream right away is that, um, it was apparently, I preloaded it, I literally preloaded it, like, the moment I woke up, and, and then, like, it was unpacking and everything, so that's why I was taking a while,
and I had to restart stream to activate the game, because even though it was exactly 7pm, it didn't activate until I restarted my stream, and now, now we're waiting for the shader, the shader compilation in progress, but I'm super excited, I'm, I'm so fucking excited to play this game on launch,
um, I remember we've been following the progress of, uh, Shroom Hong, or, like, uh, Wukong, for, or Black Myth Wukong, for, like, a very long time now, um, Israel, well, thank you for the 20 gifted ships, thank you, thank you, we've seen so many trailers,
and everything, and, uh, Journey to the West, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and,
and, and, and This is the first sentence.
And this is the first sentence.
This is the first sentence.
Dynasty Warriors.
We have Dynasty Warriors for Romance of the Three Kingdoms, but I feel like I've never seen an actual, like, good video game or, like, any types of video game adaptations of this literature.
And I was actually really scared because, you know, during, like, the final trailer reveals, there wasn't really much gameplay trailers, so I was super scared.
I was like, oh no, I haven't seen any gameplay trailers.
Recently, of this game.
So, it's like, it's just like, oh no.
Oh no, this is mean, is it gonna be good?
Is it?
So, I'm really happy to find out that the reviews for it was really, because I saw the reviews for it, and the reviews has been very positive.
So, that's great.
I'm so happy that the reviews have been very positive.
So far.
And, uh, and I'm definitely looking forward to trying it out.
It's got, like, 8 out of 10 to 10 out of 10.
Um, it's generally very favorable reviews.
The only critiques I saw was, like, gameplay-wise was, uh, was the fact that, um, it does get a little bit repetitive in the end.
Um, so, is there...
So, like, uh, I heard that, um, this game, because this game was originally...
It was, like, made, animated in Chinese, like, the lip-syncing.
So, like, I wonder if it...
Oh, I cannot read that.
Like...
But I don't want to read.
So, like...
I know, like, the lip-syncing was originally for Chinese, but, like, I don't want to read.
I don't want to...
I want them to tell me what to do.
I don't want to, like, hear...
Like, I don't want...
I don't want them to, like, make me read the instructions.
I can understand, like, bits and pieces, but, like, I'm really bad at, like, complicated words.
Like...
I'm not meant to, like, understand, like, the actual, like, like, hard words.
And Journey to the West has a lot of text, I assume, because the story itself is very complicated.
Like, not...
I don't want to say very complicated, but...
Whoa!
Don't worry, I'm gonna...
I'm gonna fix the settings when we're in there.
When we're...
Okay, it might look...
Look a little fucked right now, but don't worry.
We're gonna fix the settings when I'm in.
We're almost there.
I can't fix it yet.
I'm not in yet.
It's still loading.
Oh.
Oh!
Oh my god, he's...
There he is!
I was gonna say...
He's so handsome, but I'm like...
But he's monkey!
He...
He is...
He is a good-looking monkey.
Okay, let me...
Plug in my controller.
Why is it not registering my controller?
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
Alright, gameplay.
Tutorial.
Autolock.
Camera assist.
Show headgear.
Uh...
Damage numbers.
Enemy health bar.
Boss.
Okay.
Uh...
Camera.
Let's see.
I'm gonna turn that down, just in case.
Uh...
Language.
Display.
Okay.
Uh...
I feel like...
Okay.
Borderless.
Automatic.
Frame rate.
Cap.
Let's get to 120, just in case.
Motion blur is strong!
Oh, no camera shake, please.
I am not here for that camera shake.
Okay.
Super.
Super resolution.
And improve full ray tra...
Cinematic.
Wait, what?
What's cinematic?
Is cinematic, like, extreme?
Uh...
Is that...
Keep that...
Yeah, keep that motion blur out of there.
Absolute...
Is that ultra?
Oh, but, like, I don't know.
We'll do...
We'll do, like, very high.
Yeah, but, like, I don't know if...
Like, my PC can handle cinematic.
I...
I heard that, like, it's not very well optimized.
So, I rather...
I rather not risk it.
Look.
Look, all I'm saying is that in, like, the literature, he's, like, the most handsome monkey in...
He's the most handsome monkey...
He, like...
He begs so many ladies!
He had so many girlfriends!
He had...
Human girlfriends!
So...
He had human girlfriends!
You can't say that!
And the literature in all the video adaptations!
Apply.
We'll do high, just in case.
Uh...
Sound...
Accessibility...
Okay, that should be good.
All right.
I did do the benchmark test, but then, like, it was really hard to actually figure out if it did do anything.
So...
All right, let me turn it up in advance.
All right, here we go!
New journey!
We're going to return to Monkey!
Whoa!
Look at him.
I'm pretty sure he described how terrifying the literature to a point people thought he was a demon.
Yeah, but why does he have so many human girlfriends?
Huh?
Even goddesses wanted to bang that monkey!
Even the goddesses wanted to be some action with that monkey.
They wanted to return a monkey
Whoa He had the monkey riz
Oh, that looks so cool.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, this graphics was really good even on high
Of course you fucking hated the gods There's a reason why he got like he's going to the West cuz he has to learn his lesson Cuz he was a cocky little bitch
All right, oh that's a lot of people
Oh I love the armor design.
Oh my god
Guys the texture was is really tiny for subtitles There's a reason why we're not doing Chinese dub look how tiny the subtitles are we were never gonna get through this
I understand Hakeem sound low don't worry.
I got you guys They send you in those knuckleheads to threaten me to obey and serve once more I Understand that too But what I don't understand You killing my kind We can't have Wait that's a dad!
That's a dad!
That's the Dynasty Warriors sound effect!
I recognize that!
I recognize that Dynasty Warriors start that you!
I
played too many Dynasty Warriors to recognize that instantly.
Did he give the dog a sword?
No, don't say that.
He's a good boy Look at him.
He looks nice He's not just any monkey He's a monkey of merit.
That's right.
I can change None other than me Can challenge him to a duel.
Oh, yeah, I'm gonna beat your ass.
We all know All the iterations that clearly I'm gonna win right guys Yeah, this time it'll be different guys Here's my offer if you lose I'll take you to the celestial court.
They will stay and level your mountain But if I lose I shall certainly take revenge and they will level your mountain nonetheless
How tragic would that be?
You are one of the court We don't need to resort to the violence How about you bend the knees I'll never bend my knees to a god And you can put this behind us All
these years Except for that pig you're the one who talks the tallest tales good.
I am entertained He's totally gonna win guys Look at him.
He has so much armor I pluck your extra eye out for my And allow you to keep the other two Because I'd hate to let you miss how I'll slaughter each mongrel of the court those below those above and that black mutt of yours Noooo This dog's a good boy Wukong He's a good boy.
Oh, okay Wait, wait, where's my control?
controller not registering Oh nooo Don't know if you don't fucking you know, I can use the apple keyboard.
Fuck you I can do this.
Alright.
Oh, you start the keyboard Oh shit.
All right All right, I'm gonna put it feature as I'm clearly gonna win.
Right?
Oh guys, guys.
Why does he have so much HP?
I I don't know what my My abilities are, like I'm using everything.
Oh shit!
Multiple!
That's why the ladies love me.
And they're the reason why all the ladies love me.
Oh shit!
I didn't mean that!
That's like great.
Which was the real one?
You'll never know.
You'll never know which is the real Chum Hong.
How is he going to hit me when there's so many of me?
Have you any idea how many would give their everything for immortality?
Immortality?
For that word, all realms and beings have ruined themselves.
Oh okay, don't worry.
Thunder, freeze!
Oh shit!
That's fucking right!
What are you gonna do now, bitch?
But like, it's like not offensive in any way.
But I did not mean that Erlan.
Oh, okay.
What the fuck?
What?
How is he gonna do that?
Okay.
Oh.
This is so fucking easy.
I'm gonna send multiple monkeys in soon.
Oh shit!
Oh, dodge!
No!
I dodged into it!
Don't worry.
Oh!
This is like immort... uh... what's it called?
It's like, um...
Alright, that's right.
I'm gonna send an army.
Oh, never mind.
Alright.
We're fine.
Haha!
That's right!
That's not the real me!
That's fucking right!
Alright.
That's not fair!
You got cutscene buff!
The celestial court welcomes you, foul monkey, yet you remain untamed.
That's right.
I'm fucking...
You look wild!
You can't stop me!
Dear brother, your edge is on me.
Are they?
Wait, I don't remember him becau- Hahaha!
Backscratcher!
Hahaha!
Alright.
Oh shit!
Wait, that's not fair.
What's he gonna do?
That's right.
Oh, that's what he's gonna- Wait, but it went stone for him!
Oh, I'm gonna die!
Hahaha!
Wait!
Oh no.
Guys, it's not good.
It's not looking good.
I'm literally so c- Wait, where is my HP?
Wait, haha!
Wait a minute.
I thought that was my- Wait, do I not have HP?
Oh my god, I am immortal!
That's fucking right.
You have fucking HP.
I don't.
Hahaha!
I don't even know where- Wait, I have infinite HP?
I can never lose!
Oh my god!
I am a god!
I can never lose!
Alright, nice.
Alright.
You know what I mean?
Master Keeper's not that bad.
Hahaha!
Never punished!
I can never lose!
Jeez.
I love the- I love the music.
The music is so good.
The music is
so good.
They touched this!
Brother!
What if we touch that?
Jesus Christ.
Why don't the big guys just step on him?
Foul monkey!
Taste my axe!
That's like a million dead people right there.
For just one monkey?
You call that a deal?
The glare up here is dazzling.
Fight me in the woods if you have the guts.
Lol, he missed.
Hahaha!
Imagine missing.
What the fuck did I hit?
No!
Not the fucking bike!
How did he- How did you hit me?
No!
My powers!
That's illegal!
Not the crowd!
Oh my god!
The- The anti-cheat!
Hahaha!
Oh my god!
They caught me!
They realized I was hacking!
They put anti-cheat!
Hahaha!
The anti-cheat kicked in.
A hero.
A battle eye!
Above all else.
Buddhahood he attained, yes.
But- He found the celestial rules.
For he yearned to come back.
And to revel in the simple joys with us.
That was a great game!
Wow!
And then Wukong- Wukong got nerfed.
His choice to forgo the life above.
Only fueled their mistrust.
GG!
Hahaha!
I was a Wukong main.
But then they- he wanted mejor deixado.
He went to another planet.
Because he didn't like anything in there.
He was far more paid to do something ...
about this one.
Like now, I'm gonna play a doncaster.
He accepted that right from the start.
In his next turn on theçƒI am a number 2.
He lost 5% of his pueda 2 exports.
This is-
That's insane!
How come some monkeys wear clothes, and some do not?
That's...
Let them be free!
Dr.
Zaius, Dr. Zaius.
Monkey, why are you wearing clothes?
It's restraining you!
Let them be free!
I cannot venture through all the lands.
I cannot.
Yet among you, there might be one who is destined.
Trip the monkey!
They don't need clothes.
They have fur!
Or hair.
And upon the return of the relics to Mount Tuago, he may yet rise again.
Exactly.
Pants are a prisoner.
Maybe it's a gloofy Pluto sort of difference.
Lord Crows says thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Monkey doesn't need... pants?
Chapter 1, Black Cloud, Red Fire.
I'm actually curious what Wukong sounds like in Chinese.
Because the lip-syncing was originally done for Chinese instead of English dub.
God, that Peach looks... that Peach has fur!
That's some good render.
Is that... that's not a monkey!
You don't need clothes!
You have fur!
Perfect timing.
This Peach knew I needed a snack.
Oh!
What the fuck?
Alright.
Give me a sec.
Woah!
Give me a sec, wolf guys!
I need to... okay, I need to adjust the settings real quick.
Apparently, you can... adjust...
Okay, you cannot make it better, apparently.
Not...
You cannot make the text better, okay.
Alright, that's awkward.
Alright.
Change the... the setting... okay.
Alright, so... speech.
Alright, I'm curious.
Oh yeah.
Oh yeah, the sound effects too.
Let me turn down the sound effects.
Alright.
Alright, let me know if that's better, sound guy.
Alright, lock in... oh!
One more thing.
I swear this is the last thing!
I need to change the... the sense.
Where the fuck is the sense?
Okay, there we go.
Controller... balance... 4... 3... there we go.
That should be better now.
Nice.
That was easy.
Look at you.
Oh my god, this is giving me, like, nostalgia.
The voice acting.
Holy shit.
Okay, shift to run.
Ooh, berries.
Those are some weak-ass wolves.
I know, right?
Get outta here, wolves.
Oh, I got stone spirit and a tiny piece of gold.
Guys, I cannot keep it Chinese, guys.
I'll have to start reading later.
If I keep it Chinese.
If I don't understand something, I have to read.
And I don't know if I like that.
Oh.
Hold to charge and build up the focus.
Hold heavy attack to charge.
Charging costs stamina, but quickly builds.
Okay.
Boom!
Alright.
Nice.
I wanna hear, I wanna hear Shroom Hong talk!
Let me hear him talk!
Stop being so stoic!
Alright.
See, open.
Rainbows, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You said you don't read.
Exactly!
And that is why I don't play.
I cannot play it in full Chinese.
Because then I'll be like...
Because then I actually have to read.
Oh, yeah.
Oh.
Is that like the checkpoint?
Wait.
Oh, he has a fucking back scratcher!
Oh my god.
That's when you know he's old, old.
He's so itchy.
Grandpa, is that you?
Okay.
Oh...
Hi,
Grandpa.
Oh, nice.
More wolves?
Don't worry, I'll beat your ass.
Goodbye, Grandpa!
I gotta backtrack.
How can they be tough?
Alright, offer incense.
What is this?
Are these upgrades or bonfire?
Oh!
Collect gifts.
Oh yeah!
I bought the deluxe!
That's right!
Pay to win!
That's fucking right.
Yeah, I'm pay to win.
Where is it?
Oh yeah, I am pay to win.
Yeah, that's right.
14 defense.
Let's fucking go.
Oh yeah, slightly increased movement speed.
That's what I like to see.
Pay to win!
Oh, but his hat's so... Okay, let me...
I need to turn off the hat.
Oh, I don't like the hat.
I know you can turn it off.
Okay, we're gonna put English until he fucking talks.
The monkey isn't talking!
Donkey man!
No, I wanna see his face!
I know you can make it so you can see his face!
Alright, helmet.
Where the fuck's the helmet?
Oh, show headgear.
Okay, off.
Pay to win time.
Alright.
The English voice acting is actually surprisingly very...
It's pretty decent.
Like, it's very, like, similar to the Chinese.
Pay to win, but...
Zachary, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you!
Alright, let's see.
Hello, wolf.
You have a shield?
Shield's not gonna help you!
I have a long-ass pole!
Oh, shit!
Guys, I think the shield helped him.
Oh, no!
No!
Okay.
I need to lock in.
There we go.
That's fucking right.
Shield doesn't help you.
Help Jack.
Jack shit.
Okay.
No talk.
Only monkey.
That's fucking right.
What's the axe gonna do?
Oh, sorry.
I keep forgetting to lock in.
That's fucking right.
Oh!
That's what the axe is gonna do.
Don't worry.
I charge up.
Thank you for watching me charge it up.
Shield.
Yeah, that's right.
Shield versus pay to win staff.
That's right.
I don't like how there's no compass.
Guys, I'm a little bit worried because there's no compass.
And I feel like I won't know where to go soon.
All right.
Nice.
Oh, hey!
There's a big guy over there.
Surely, he's not gonna fucking kill me, right?
Oh!
All right.
Never mind.
Cat guy.
Okay.
Bull guard.
All right.
Oh!
How the fuck?
That's illegal.
Are you serious?
Guys, I think he killed me.
But I paid a win!
Is that possible?
I paid a win!
Okay.
I believe they should be respawning, right?
Just like Dark Souls?
You didn't even get it.
Thank you for the akasupa.
Thank you.
He's like three times my size!
Like, what the fuck was I supposed to do?
He's three times my size!
I wonder, like, if, like, my XP is, like, there or some shit.
It's not fair!
The anti-cheat got me!
I got...
My main account got VAC banned!
It's not fair!
What was I supposed to do?
I have to restart from zero on a new account!
Okay.
All my money and gold and assets were...
Oh, shit!
Damn.
Don't understand!
Oh, shit!
Okay.
Nice.
I dodged it.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh!
Okay.
I'm gonna do some hard attacks here.
This is the same...
Oh, shit!
Okay.
Oh!
Where am I?
Wait!
That's cheating!
He has cutscene!
What?
Oh, shit!
Oh, my God!
Oh, man!
You did it!
The navigation is simple.
Just...
Just head west.
Thank you for the super chat, Zane!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Thank you, old man!
Oh!
I'm gonna have the ability!
Immobilize!
Oh, my God!
Guys!
I'm slowly getting back my main!
Should you come across any miscreants, just point your finger at them and release this spell.
You'll be able to hold them in place while giving yourself a...
I got the monkey paw!
Sadly, mine is but a humble trick.
Yeah, who would lose to this guy?
It couldn't be me.
Oh shit!
Okay, don't worry.
Watch this.
That's fucking right.
I missed.
Okay, I won't miss a second time.
My pull was so long!
How was I missing?
Oh, my stamina is running out.
Fuck!
Okay.
I need to make sure I have enough stamina too.
Easy.
Missing stationary target.
I don't know what you're talking about.
What if I could explore?
I feel like I won't find my way back.
That's like what I'm scared about.
I feel like I'm gonna start exploring and then I'll be like, how do I go back?
Oh, there's a bird!
There's a rabbit!
Oh, I can't kill the rabbit.
What are you?
Are you a rat?
Are you scared?
Oh, bamboo!
Why are you scared?
Why can't I go down?
Who's this guy?
How do I...
How do I interact with it?
Oh, E.
The form.
The shaka form.
Okay.
Gotta explore it a little bit.
Oh, there's more loot!
Wait, how do I get that?
Give me the loot!
Alright, gather.
The purple Lindsay.
Two more stuff.
Guys, I need you guys to help.
You're my GPS, okay?
So I can go back the right way later.
What are you gonna do about it?
Nothing.
That's fucking right.
You're weak as fuck.
I literally killed a bull guard.
Nice.
Already guarding a plant.
Guys, where's West?
Guys, we need to head to the...
What the fuck is that?
Oh, there's frog people!
Oh.
Get back here.
Get back over here.
You think you can hop away?
New lesser yoga has been recorded.
Where are you?
Croaky.
Impose a jewel.
Forms unrefined.
Ugly and odd.
Damn.
Voices... Bellies... Damn.
Okay.
Two frog-wise practiced in the marshes.
The smaller frog was often bullied.
Yet the bigger frog one always stood up for him.
Instead, they forged a strong friendship.
One day, they made a contest held by Law Ikalan to appoint a surgeon among all the frogs.
Guys, I don't...
Guys, just buy Journey to the West.
Guys, this is basically Journey to the West excerpts.
Oh, I love the artwork though.
The wolf swordsman.
Among the wolf guays, there was a young one.
Wolf guay.
There was a young one.
Guay!
Oh, it's monster!
I was like, guay.
Guay.
More guay!
That's monster in Chinese.
However, his time spent practicing was short in his skill.
Oh.
Alright, let's see.
I just realized what it meant.
I was like, guay.
Guay.
More guay.
Self-advanced?
Oh, is this rank up?
Oh, okay.
Uh...
Question, should I stream on YouTube or on Twitch?
It will be my first time.
Daniel, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Definitely Twitch.
If you're like streaming for the first time.
I don't know what to get.
Literally, the game just came out.
It's like since...
Oh, wait.
I like that.
I want extend the immobilize.
Oh my god, there's no meta.
Literally, the game just came out, so there's no meta.
I...
It's not fair.
There's no meta.
The game literally just came out.
Increases the health recovery among assuming a focus point.
I like that.
Enables sprinting when charging.
Okay, wait.
That's good.
Foundations.
Staminy talent.
Reduces the smartly.
Reduces the stamina cost.
Okay, I feel like we got reduced to dodging stamina.
All right.
Oh, no.
We're metacrafting now.
We're metacrafting for now.
All right.
I wonder what would happen if I put no caps for FPS frames.
Who would that be like?
Who are you?
You don't seem...
Are you a crow?
Oh, it's a crow!
Oh, shit!
Oh!
Give me heals.
I don't...
I have heals.
Okay.
Nice.
Increase the duration if I use this.
Oh, fuck!
That's not fair!
He has the strong legs!
He's so fast!
Okay.
Oh!
How does he hit me from there?
It's okay.
I'll just L1 it.
Oh, please.
Oh, shit!
Drink.
Okay.
I still have heals.
That's fucking right!
Oh, shit!
I'll brute force it.
Nice.
I did it.
Wait.
It's a lesser...
It's a lesser monster?
But, like, he's so strong.
But he was so strong.
His stick was longer.
It's not fair.
Okay.
At least I got more willpower now.
Is that it?
Was that what you wanted?
Is that what he's guarding?
All right.
Learn to dodge?
I don't know the timing for the dodges.
I feel like I thought I timed it correctly, but I haven't learned the dot timing yet.
Don't worry.
If I bash my head against the wall enough times, it'll work.
That's the Doki way.
I'll figure it out!
Guys, I'm lost.
Which way is west?
Just don't get it.
Okay.
I'm going to try uncapping the frames and see if...
I want to see how that affects my game.
All right.
This is it.
Now I can't be stopped.
Guys, where's west?
Oh, it looks so much better.
Hole!
Oh, die!
There it is!
Oh, my God.
We found west.
Guys, we found it!
All right.
Open self-advanced to awaken talents.
Level up to...
Oh, I literally just did that.
That has to be the level up stuff.
There shouldn't be any motion blur.
I turn it off.
That's right.
No praying for you.
I need your XP.
I need willpower.
All right.
That's it.
That's right.
No praying for you either.
I need to consume your will.
That's right.
Don't worry.
You're just going to have to...
Hell's not that bad.
I couldn't scatter this.
Wow, you disturbed his prayer.
Look, I saw some juicy XP in him.
All right.
Let's go this way.
Oh.
Is that more XP?
Hello.
Hello, frog guy.
Oh, shit.
You have a friend.
Oh, you had...
Oh, I forgot to heal.
You had a friend.
Now you'll both see each other in hell.
All right.
See?
It's not that bad.
I need to find a shrine.
An incense shrine.
Oh, there it is.
Is that a shrine?
No.
That's just...
Is that...
What is that?
That's just decoration.
Okay.
God damn it.
All right.
Wait.
There's more stuff there.
Did I miss the items?
Oh.
Lily pad.
I'll figure out what these items will do one day.
Oh, I don't have heals.
Wait.
Is that poison?
Oh, that was poison.
I was...
I was in the swamp.
No.
Please.
Thank you.
No.
I didn't realize.
I was like...
Why am I glowing green?
Why?
I didn't realize.
I didn't...
I was like...
Wow.
I wonder why I'm glowing green, guys.
I...
No.
I was like...
Uh oh.
Stinky.
No.
I was like...
Oh!
I can't believe it!
They have poisonous swans?!
No!
I can't believe they have poins...
I'm just gonna run past this.
Fuck this.
Gosh, this is stinky.
I couldn't tell.
I'm just like...
Oh, hey, I'm glowing green right now.
Surely that's not a bad thing, right?
I can't believe it.
Why am I glowing green?
We can't... It's alright, I gotta ruin their prayer yet again.
That's right.
Fuck the gods.
Alright, nice.
Alright.
At least I don't lose anything.
There's like... I feel like there's no cons...
Okay, we're not going back to the swamp.
I've learned my lesson.
At least there's like no consequences to... to dying.
Yeah, that green is go!
Why do you think green is not go?
Alright, let's see.
You can curse whenever you want, Daniel.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright.
I feel like... I feel like I haven't lost anything from dying.
Like, is there any punishment other than...
Yeah, green means good!
Like, what's the point of teaching me that green...
Look, willpower is green!
Do I even like lose anything?
Oh, there you go.
Thank god.
Your incense.
I feel like I didn't lose anything from dying.
Dignity!
Okay, other than that.
Other than my dignity.
Yeah, you don't lose anything from dying.
Green is also HP!
I'm meditating.
That's not incense.
What did I get though?
Sparks.
Oh!
What the fuck is sparks?
I can't go down.
Okay.
What the fuck is sparks?
Oh, level up.
Oh, okay.
That's the level up.
Alright.
Make each initial dodge more agile and flexible.
Increases... Okay, I feel like we definitely need stamina.
Staff spin?
Moving forward while using staff spin initiates mobile spin around...
Oh, it deflects projectiles.
That's defense.
We're not here for that.
It increases the engaged...
Oh!
I like distance!
Guys, we're not here to defend.
Alright.
We don't need defense.
I have a longer staff now.
Alright, is there anything here?
Alright, see?
That's green.
Will is green.
Alright, in I go.
Ooh.
Oh my god!
The game was like, you're taking too long.
So here's like a guide.
Thank you, game.
Thank you, video game.
You know what I wanted.
Alright.
We lit another bonfire.
Rest.
Fully restores.
Self-advance.
Oh, you want to use in combat?
Reunite the sparks?
What is that?
Oh!
You get to reset your thing!
So like, if you don't like it, you can reset everything.
And then there's obviously gonna be more stamina.
And then there's gonna be more spells in the future.
There's stores?
Who am I buying this from?
Evil repellent.
Upon using, it increases damage.
Yarn.
By day, they patrol the hills.
By night, they spin their yarns.
Such is the life of Lesser Iguais.
They're hard to earn yarns.
Okay, so that's for crafting.
And then this is for medicine.
So this is how I'm gonna make medicine.
But how do I like...
Oh, and then I can sell my gold.
Can I sell my gold?
Yeah.
I guess I'll sell my gold.
Uhh...
Okay.
So then that means I can sell my gold here.
I guess I'll just sell all my gold, right?
Because this is the keepers shrine.
Right guys.
Is this the Keeper Shrine?
Uh...
Yeah,
all right, I'll just sell all of this.
I was worried that I'm not at the right shrine, all right?
Probably you're right.
We're all experiencing this at the same time.
I forgot today's launch day, guys.
Like, nobody knows what's going on.
You know what?
Fuck it.
Surely, surely it won't be... This is the shrine.
Surely.
No.
I can't.
There's no way.
There's no way this isn't.
Surely I didn't fuck it up.
Okay.
This has to be it.
We're doing it for science.
Wait, why did you sell your gold?
That's not the key for shrine.
Go ahead.
Let me transform you into a golden cicada.
So you may follow the fires ahead.
Scout this mountain unnoticed...
Monkey want to fight.
Monkey don't want be no pussy cicada.
No!
Now all we we're gonna do is wanna fuck now.
That's why... that's... you know...
You know that's why comin...
The cicadas scream, right?
Because they are telling the whole world that it's the season.
What happened?
Okay, I just need to...
That's why they scream.
They are like, it's time.
What is that?
What?
Hey, guys.
Hey.
The master?
Who's the master?
Hey, guys.
Man, that's so weird.
The cicada won't fucking leave.
Hey.
Hey, guys.
What are you talking about?
What the fuck do I want gold, man?
You turned me into a cicada.
I don't know where to go.
Oh my god, why do they hate monkey?
You have a time limit?
Where?
There's no time limit anywhere.
Whoa!
That's a big boy.
Oh, wait.
Is that my stamina?
Oh, it's my stamina, guys.
Hey, cicada noises.
Wait, I want to look at this big boy.
Look at him.
He's so big.
Oh, shit!
Guys, I fucked up.
Oh, shit.
I just wanted to look at the big boy.
Oh, god.
Okay, he's not following me.
That's good.
I just wanted to look at him.
I just wanted to see what he's doing.
Perform the block incoming.
Oh, okay, now.
Oh, I already had it.
Okay, guys.
Alright.
Okay,
guys.
Alright.
I just wanted...
I wanted this.
How did it...
Okay, I was on fire.
It's okay.
I wanted the cicada powers.
Is he gonna give me cicada powers again?
Oh, no.
Oh, okay.
Alright.
Made a fucked up.
Guys.
Oh, shit.
Don't worry.
No moving for you.
Okay, we're okay.
We're slowly learning, guys.
Alright.
Guys, look!
I dodged!
I did it!
I can learn!
Alright.
I...
Oh, man.
He gave me the cicada...
I didn't realize it was one time use only.
I thought he would come back to give me cicada powers.
I didn't...
How was I supposed to know it was one use only?
I was being...
I was being cocky!
I was fucking around!
Oh, man!
I'm sorry!
I didn't learn my lesson!
No cicada for you.
Who are you?
Oh, ogre!
Oh!
Did you see that dodge?
Oh, shit!
Okay, but not that one, though.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Alright.
Immobile!
Here we go.
You literally said time limit, but I never listen!
That's the thing!
Who is this guy?
Oh, bandit chief?
And by God's sake, I lived a youth in town.
Alright.
Nice!
I leveled up!
He was guarding this!
What did I get?
I got evil repellent and tiny piece of gold.
Okay.
Somewhere I learned this time.
That's fucking right.
I'm coming in.
You thought you could use arrows?
This is the very first time I've seen you, man.
Never seen you before in my life.
Very first fight, guys.
Very first fight.
What the fuck?
Oh, shit.
I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry, man.
I didn't realize...
I didn't realize I...
Oh, I didn't realize I pulled your hair!
I pulled a nerve ending!
Whoa!
Okay.
Holy shit, he's so tanky!
You're a plant!
How are you so tanky?
Boom.
Oh.
Alright.
Haha, look at this loser.
He tripped and fell.
Easy.
Oh, I got ginseng!
Where are you?
Yeah, there's a flower.
Mimic.
Gifts rocking forth from the earth.
Spirits untied.
Roots serve as limbs.
Oh, it's like a...
It's actually like a...
Mimic.
Oh, for plants.
I'm so lost.
Sir, do you know where to go?
I don't...
I don't know where to go, sir.
Alright, loot.
Why...
Why did I not scout ahead like he told me to?
Oh, no.
It's the crow.
He's so scary.
Oh, no.
It's the crow.
Mobile.
Immobile!
That's fucking right.
He has so much range.
Oh, alright.
Don't worry.
I got this.
Oh, shit!
Oh!
Dodged.
Oh, shit!
Oh!
Six or so.
He's like half my...
He's like double my size!
I'm getting better at the combat, though.
Oh, nice.
Nice.
Alright.
We got another spark.
Oh, he was just trying to meditate in the water.
You know like in...
In like Chinese films?
In shows?
They like meditate in the water to increase their toughness or whatever?
That's what he was doing.
Didn't help him.
I can't even read and I beat your ass.
Let's see.
Where the fuck am I?
Where...
This entire game is just like, where am I?
Oh, I can level up now.
Oh...
More agile and flexible.
Monitoring costs stamina.
While using...
Okay, we don't...
Oh!
Okay, maybe we should...
We should have this so we can actually like move forward.
Level significantly increases...
Alright, that's...
We should grab...
Stances.
Uses a health recover upon...
Enable sprinting while charging.
Do I have this yet?
No.
Switching to allows...
the destined one to support himself...
and ascend.
The more focus he builds, the higher he perches.
I don't know.
There's so many talents.
There's no meta.
This game literally just came out.
So many choices.
I'm so bad at making decisions.
Water increases damage.
The...
That's good!
That increases more damage.
I don't know how to metacraft!
Alright.
What are you gonna do?
Fucking watch your friend die?
He's like...
Wait, I don't know that guy.
Alright.
Think like a...
What would Monkey do?
Am I supposed to fight the big guy?
Oh.
How dare you interrupt my meditation?
Hello?
Oh, that's another big guy.
Wait, there's two big guys?
Oh no.
You know what?
I'll do this big guy first and then we'll do the other big guy.
Hello, sir!
I'm just a little monkey.
I'm not here to do anything bad.
Another monkey I see.
That's me.
Oh no, he's wolf.
Kwanzee.
Oh!
Yes!
We're gonna meditate, right?
This doesn't look like meditating, sir.
Oh no.
Oh shit, no!
Okay.
What the fuck?
You.
Okay.
Fine.
We're fine.
What?
Oh no.
This is not fine.
We're not fine.
We're not.
We're not fine!
Okay, that's how the dodges work.
No!
What?
We're not fine.
Can I leave?
Whoa!
Oh shit.
What are these attacks?
I'm fucking leaving.
No!
Oh my god.
He has so many fucking...
Oh god.
He has so many attacks.
Wait, can I cheese this here?
What if I...
There's no way he can get me here.
Oh no.
I have insignificant mana?
What do you mean I can't cheese?
Okay, but what if I cheese it here?
How many attacks does he have?
He has so...
That's bullshit!
That guy has like...
7 plus different attack combos!
I...
He can also jump?
Like...
Like it's so fair!
He has so many!
He has so...
He has so many different attacks!
There's no cheese for you.
He has like 5 MILLION DIFFERENT ATTACKS!
Just use the same talent Bill from Journey to the West wrote the meta hundreds of years ago.
Thank you Marino.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
Please don't tell me there's another phase too.
Like how he was still watching his friend.
He's just like, please man, I was just watching.
He melted the cheese.
Oh my god.
Thank you.
Okay, we can do this.
Hello sir, I'm back.
I need to download your controls again.
Alright, nice.
Oh shit!
No, nice!
I think his thing is too like there was no difficulty setting.
You go straight in.
It is literally Dark Souls.
I feel like this is...
Except the fact that dying has no consequences.
Ah!
Again!
Please!
Oh my god!
Oh god, okay.
Oh, no!
No!
You're still going!
Bitch!
You have so many attacks!
Oh god.
No!
Alright.
Dodge!
Okay.
Jesus Christ!
Oh!
No!
Roll!
Stop dropping!
Oh!
Please sir!
Oh shit!
I already got half way!
Oh!
Oh my god!
What would my ancestors do?
Stop!
Drop!
Oh my god!
He's so fast!
Why did I not pack more cords?
I...
Oh!
Please don't tell me there's space too!
Okay.
I can figure this out.
This guy!
Okay!
Unlike Souls games, like, they don't have fucking one million movesets!
I swear to god!
He has like two million movesets!
I swear to fucking god!
I feel like I'm...
Every time I fight him, I see a new move!
He didn't even jump that time!
He has
two hundred million moves!
I...
Okay.
Oh...
It is an Elden Ring?
Oh my god.
Okay.
I still need to figure out the timing for the dodges!
I'm so fucking stupid!
Alright.
Don't worry.
I figured it out.
Okay.
This is... This time it'll be different.
I figured it out.
I got this.
Get over here.
Wait, wait.
Not...
Oh god.
Okay.
Alright.
I was like, wait a minute.
I didn't mean that.
Wow!
What did you fucking...
Okay.
Alright.
That's one of them.
No!
Oh!
Stop!
Alright.
Ah!
Fuck!
Please!
Sir!
I'm just trying to find some bananas!
Oh!
Okay.
How does that hit me?
Alright.
Nice.
I just want...
Oh!
Alright.
I just... I got lost!
I was just trying to find bananas!
Alright.
I just got lost!
Sir!
Oh!
Come on!
Sir!
Please!
Oh!
Keep rolling!
Now... How do I stop rolling?
Oh, okay.
Get stun!
Oh, no!
I'm down in stamina!
This is bad!
No!
Nooo!
Okay.
Oh, leave me alone, please!
Leave me alone!
Please!
Okay.
No!
Oh, god!
Nooo!
Please!
Wait, can I stop rolling?!
Oh, please!
Oh, that is my way!
Oh, thank god!
Oh, god!
I can finally get banana!
Me?!
I'm just here for some bananas!
Alright.
Oh, my god!
This is a longer pull!
Surely, it'll be easier now!
That's the very very very intense vibe of each thrust.
The flames do rise.
Transform into a wolf guai and inflict scorch.
Oh, I can be a wolf?!
I can have the wolf inside me?!
Alright.
Weapons and valuable chairs by Yao Guai often carry lingering obsessions from the deceased's owners.
Collect them, granting them the ability to swiftly take their form in combat.
Each transformation has its own strength, making them worth experimenting with.
Oh, you can like change your style!
Using spells during further depletes might, and once it's fully...
Oh, so it's like...
It's like a special power!
I got the dog in me.
Alright.
Do I have to change my weapon?
Or is it this?
Wait, how do I...
How do I...
activate it, though?
Increases damage...
Oh, I should've...
Oh, thank god I didn't use that.
Thank god.
Uh...
It's a transform...
Oh, it's the magic then!
Holy shit.
Hahaha!
Oh my god.
I can't believe I got...
I...
Oh my god.
It says action RPG, but in the end it was actually...
Action Souls!
We better dodge.
Please, somebody...
Heal me.
Okay, no, I ran out of drinks.
Okay, where's my...
Okay, this is...
Oh!
I'm Wolf now!
Okay, light, heavy...
I see.
Where's my magic?
Though.
Only say series...
Alright.
Souls is action RPG.
RPG.
Hahaha!
Did you watch the Hong Kong TV series Journey to the West when you were...
Yes!
I did!
I was thinking of the Super Chat thinking that...
Yeah, we were talking about that earlier.
In the beginning.
Ring.
I killed your dad.
That's right.
That was me.
I did that.
Everyone must know!
Hahaha!
First try!
Let them all know!
I first tried him!
Real!
Hahaha!
Now all of the West know!
They gotta know that I totally definitely first tried him!
Let's see.
Oh, God, I need heals so badly.
I'm gonna like walk up to the first guy I see and get slapped and then die.
There's no way.
Alright.
What's this here?
Oh!
Okay.
That is just loot.
Is that it?
I cannot jump.
I can only roll.
I don't have the power of jump yet.
Holy shit.
We're so...
Is there anything up here?
Why is there a platform here?
Okay.
Surely nothing bad is gonna happen, right?
Right?
Hahaha!
Yeah!
Whoa!
Oh, God!
Oh, that was close!
Yeah, I'm going back to the shrine.
I need to heal so badly.
Alright.
I need to figure out where...
GPS!
Okay.
Oh, yeah.
I forgot about the other big boy.
It's okay.
The other big boy wasn't important.
He didn't get a special cutscene.
Like that big boy.
Oh, God.
How do I get back?
Okay.
Up here.
And then...
Yeah.
Down here.
Please don't...
Oh, there's no fall damage.
Okay.
And...
Uh...
Everything looks the same.
It's just green.
Down here.
And then...
Oh, it's here!
I remember the bridge!
Okay.
And then the shrine should be like...
Back here?
Yeah!
I did it.
I figured it out.
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
We gotta rest up.
Figured it out.
Hahaha!
Okay.
We're fine.
I guess now it's the big boy time, right?
That's fucking right.
Wait.
If I transform into a wolf, do they see me as them?
All right.
Let's try.
Okay.
Hello!
I'm just like you!
Are we friends?
We're not friends.
Hahaha!
Okay.
We could've been friends!
But I saw you raise your fucking stick!
You think I didn't, no?
Okay.
He raised his axe.
So, we are not friends.
All right.
Okay.
Oh, why did I use that?
I should...
Okay, guys.
We gotta wait now.
We...
Hahaha!
I didn't realize he was right there!
I didn't realize!
Now I have to wait for my chance!
Transformation!
I didn't realize he was right here!
All right.
While we're doing...
Waiting.
Let's figure out upgrades.
Oh, this is...
Let's be transforming.
Right?
Transforming, right?
Modern increases damage of the next...
Cannot awaken.
So, like, after getting there, I can awaken this.
Um...
Okay.
I can upgrade this even more.
Stances.
Um...
Okay.
Maybe we got...
That's lifesteal, right?
This has to be lifesteal.
Okay.
All right.
This is fine.
Okay.
We're almost there.
Give me a sec, bro.
I need a...
Give me a sec, man.
I need to wait for the cooldown.
I wasted wolf form on another wolf.
It was wolf on wolf violence.
I couldn't help it.
I couldn't help it, man.
I thought we could be friends.
I thought now that I was a wolf, he wouldn't be, like, specious towards me.
Because he's like, oh, yeah, I just hate monkeys.
You know?
But no.
He hates even wolves.
He also hated wolves, too.
He just hated everybody.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Please.
This cooldown is so long.
Okay.
By the time I get to him, I would have finished the cooldown.
Guys, don't worry.
That's why he doesn't expect a thing.
That's fucking right.
He'd never expect anything.
Boom.
Oh, yeah.
He's crying.
Little bitch.
Oh, shit.
I'm stuck.
Oh, God.
I didn't mean that.
Oh.
Oh, God.
What the fuck?
Wait.
What?
He can do that?
Oh, God.
I need to redo my stamina.
Okay.
Oh.
I didn't know he could do that.
Don't worry.
What?
Okay.
That's it.
Don't worry.
I've got the wolf in me now.
Okay.
That's fucking right.
Not what you're gonna do.
I've got the wolf in me.
That's fucking right.
That's right.
No.
I'm hurt.
Oh, shit.
Oh.
It's okay.
I know that's... that will hurt me.
Okay.
I don't like how... you know.
I'm barely doing any damage right now.
That's the...
Oh, nice.
That's fucking right.
That's fucking right, baby.
Nice.
Nice dodge.
Oh, what?
That should be legal.
That was so much damage.
It's actually not fair.
Why?
He's so...
It's like he's so big.
It's like the bigger he is, the more strength he has.
What?
Oh my god!
That should be illegal!
Have you tried it, Doki?
There's this new meta that they developed.
It's called dodging.
Oh my god, now I wasted... now I'm like 1 HP short from it.
No!
I'm letting the Woldrig... he got in my head!
The big baby got in my head!
Now I'm getting hit!
Okay, nice.
Get open!
He's in my head!
Alright.
Big baby.
I'll beat you up, big baby.
That's fucking right.
Oh my god, he's so strong!
No!
God damn it!
Whoa!
Big baby!
What the fuck?!
Where do I... where do I fucking go at that point?!
Jesus Christ!
Holy shit!
No!
Wolfguy is not doing so well, guys.
It's okay, I might be dead here.
Holy shit.
Okay, there's no way he can break that rock.
Rock, right?
Tree doesn't block him?
Okay, but like...
Why can't we be friends?
Oh!
Whoa!
Why can't we... does he respawn if I kill him?
No!
No, no, no, no, no!
What?!
You win this fight, I'm running!
Hahaha!
You win this fight, big baby!
I leave!
Oh, hey, I'm gonna gather here.
Is he gonna kill me from all the way there?
That's fucking right.
I know your range.
I know... I know your range.
It's okay, oh, it's okay.
Rematch.
We just gotta get our HP.
No!
We will kill him!
I don't even know if he respawns back.
No, he can't...
There's no way.
There's no way I can kill him.
I'm not a coward!
I'm just...
It's called Tactical Ret...
Oh, shit!
It is a Tactical Retreat!
Alright.
I'll be so sad if he respawns after everything I did.
Alright, don't worry, I figured it out.
I figured it out.
I know his... his pattern now.
That's right.
I figured you out, big baby.
I've downloaded you.
Now that I know you can jump, it's over.
That's right.
Turn around, big baby.
Turn the fuck around.
That's right.
You let your guard down.
Mistake number one!
You should never let your guard down, bitch!
Oh, you're gonna cry?
That's right.
Wolf is here now.
Wolf.
Okay.
Oh, shit!
Oh, nice.
I dodged it.
Oh, fuck!
I forgot about that, too!
It's fine.
I realize...
Yes!
Ow.
I did not dodge that.
Oh, fuck!
Okay.
It's fine.
We're fine.
We are so not fine.
Oh, nice!
Nice!
He fell down!
Good nerd.
Okay.
Whoa!
There's no way you can clap again.
Oh, shit!
He jumped!
Oh!
He headbashes!
How d'you still have new moves?!
How d'you...
How d'you still have new fucking moves?!
I...
Stop!
Jesus Christ.
God, please.
If there is a god.
You wouldn't let me live.
Okay, he got it!
He got it!
Why does this reach?
What the f**k?
He f**king ate this big baby!
F**king cry, you nerd!
I'm tempted to be dead!
Why is this so much harder against the wolf?
It's not fair!
How does he still have new moves?
How does he still...
Okay, this time I've downloaded him.
I figured it out.
Guys.
Guys, I figured it out this time.
It's over.
I figured out his movesets.
You can't do anything anymore.
I figured it out, chat.
For real.
I've downloaded him.
I don't even know if I have time to do charge attacks sometimes.
I do a lot of light attacks because I always feel like I don't have time.
Alright.
Oh sh**, baby.
Don't worry, he's gonna turn around and I'm gonna have one free hit.
Watch this.
Boom!
New hit!
That's f**king right.
Yeah, cry big baby!
Boom!
I learned.
Can't do anything now, big baby!
Oh, you're gonna fall?
Yeah, cry to your god!
Which is me!
No!
I dodged it!
Okay.
Alright.
Run, run, run!
He's still going!
What is that?
What is that combo?
He's still f**king going!
STOP!
STOP YOUR FUCKING COMBO, YOU NERD!
YOUR MOTHER DOESN'T LOVE YOU, THAT'S WHY YOU'RE ABANDONED AS A CHILD!
I CAN CRY!
THAT'S RIGHT, YOUR MOTHER HATES YOU!
Oh god, I have to dodge.
Alright.
It's okay.
There's no way this range will hit me now, right?
There's no- That's a fucking long ass- WHAT THE FUCK IS THAT RANGE?!
Okay,
yes, that will still hit me no matter what.
Okay.
Guys, I figured it out.
Alright.
I'm just like, there's no way, that- there's no way the range is that far!
There's no fucking way!
Okay.
I- I didn't think his range was that far!
I- I thought it'd be- I thought- RANGE!
How the fuck- Okay.
I'm a- I'm actually a mess.
I don't know how the fuck I missed that.
WOW, DID I MISS IT TWICE?!
NO!
I'm- I'm resetting.
This is not the right life.
This is not- This- This life wasn't it.
We gotta go to the next one.
We gotta go to the next life.
Okay, this time.
We're okay this time.
Alright.
There's no way I'll miss this time.
Boom, there we go.
Alright, I figured it out for real.
It's over for the big baby.
It's fucking over.
I figured it out this time.
This time, we figured it out.
It's gonna be so fucking easy.
Alright.
This time.
This time, big baby.
This is it.
Things will be different.
This time for real.
It's fucking right.
Charge.
Boom!
Freeze!
That's fucking right.
And then!
That's right!
Cry, you fucking baby!
Oh!
Yeah?
You're gonna do nothing!
What you gonna do?
Nothing!
I'll keep dashing!
Oh!
Okay.
Dash ended.
Alright.
That's fine.
No, that's not fine!
What?
I thought I dodged that!
Okay.
Oh!
Nice!
Good dodge!
Okay.
Oh!
No!
He clapped!
Baby can clap now, too!
Oh, no!
There's nothing coming out of my arm!
Anything but that!
Yeah, that's right.
Cry.
Oh, God.
My...
We gotta leave.
We gotta...
We gotta leave!
No!
Oh, no!
Oh, the classes!
Uh...
The...
Oh, yeah...
Yeah!
The foursplash!
The four...
Why is it so difficult?
The wolf was easier!
I...
I was there to beat the baby!
He doesn't even have parents!
He can't even see us!
I can't...
This is it.
This time.
Guys, I've learned.
I figured it out for real.
No, I healed.
I accidentally healed.
No, I will not skip the baby.
I will defeat the baby.
There is no way.
When I kill him, nobody will remember him because he has no family.
That's fucking right.
This is what I needed.
I just needed the extra spark, guys.
I just needed the extra spark.
I'll have nobody to remember me.
I'll have nobody to remember him by when I fucking kill him.
Oh my god, please.
Please.
Okay, we gotta increase.
Alright.
We gotta reduce the stamina.
Maybe this is it.
Alright.
Bam!
I will defeat the baby.
And the baby will be no more.
That's right.
I'm talking about you, big baby.
Everybody else has progressed through this game.
But I'm stuck here fighting you, baby.
Everyone else has already passed you.
But I don't care.
I will fucking kill this baby if it's the last thing I do.
I don't care.
This is my life mission now.
We will kill this big...
Oh shit!
Oh god.
Please.
There you go.
We're fine.
That's fucking right.
Dodge this.
Oh.
Wait, what the fuck?
I'm trying to kill a baby here.
What are you doing here?
Oh my god.
What the fuck are you doing?
What are you doing?
Okay.
Oh, please.
Stop slapping me, please.
Okay.
No.
Oh, no.
Nope.
Oh god.
Oh, I have to dodge this?
No, come at me.
Oh, okay.
No, come at me now.
Okay.
We got regenerate stamina.
Nice.
Okay.
Alright.
That's okay.
That's good.
Okay.
Come on.
No!
The fuck?
Maybe I was never supposed to fight him anyway.
Oh my god.
Maybe I was supposed to dodge.
Maybe I was supposed to run away from him.
We'll never know.
It's too late.
Alright.
This is it.
No, no.
I... I will stop spam dodging.
There we go.
The baby about to be a grown man by the time this is over.
This is it.
Baby, please.
Please.
Just baby.
Nobody loves you.
Just let me kill you.
I just want to live.
You look cool in front of my dragons.
You have nothing to...
Oh no!
Am I doing worse?
He fucking used his... fucking...
He used his head!
It's okay.
We're fine.
Alright.
Okay.
We did it.
We dodged everything.
Alright.
Think!
Dodge!
I don't know how to dodge!
It's okay.
We're fine.
Who are you?
What are you doing in my fight?
Please!
Use my HP!
No!
Okay.
We're okay.
Alright.
We're not okay.
We're okay.
We're not.
Oh god.
No.
No, I'm stuck!
No!
Oh!
Okay.
That's good.
That's fine.
I don't like where I am though.
Where am I?
Oh shit!
No!
Not the wolves!
It's okay.
He's so far.
There's no way he'll get to me.
Oh fuck!
What the fuck is my luck?
What the...
Holy shit.
How did he get to me?
How did he do it?
How did he...
How did he get to me?
I don't understand.
Does he not have me?
Oh my god.
I...
I don't see...
What was the baby's range?
He hasn't even gone past kindergarten.
Oh my god.
This is not looking good for me if I'm struggling so hard.
Alright, I'm a big baby.
Guys, my head is not looking very good for me, guys.
We're still stuck in big baby territory.
I just want to look cool, please.
Please, everybody, there are people already.
People already fucking unlocked.
Junhong, please.
They unlocked him already and I'm still stuck in baby level.
I'm still in baby level.
They already freed him from the fucking rock and I'm still here.
I'm still here.
Are you serious?
Oh my god.
I need a time that... I keep forgetting how to time it.
Oh, nice.
Okay.
Oh, yeah, there we go.
No, no, no, no, no.
Okay.
Nice.
No, the headbutt!
Why does he use the headbutt and why does he not headbutt?
Okay.
Alright.
Oh, god.
Okay.
No!
It's always a Kamehameha force punch!
Oh, god.
I know this range is fucking crazy, too.
Alright.
I'm getting better, guys!
Guys, is this possible?
I'm actually improving?
Yes!
Oh, I dodged it!
I did it!
Okay.
There's no way he's gonna headbutt this time.
No!
Okay.
Alright.
Guys, I cannot choose the alert.
Oh, please, no.
No, please.
Please.
Oh, god.
Oh, no.
It's this...
It's this move!
Oh!
Okay.
Alright.
Here we go.
Please.
Oh!
No!
Come on!
He jumped!
He broke my groove!
Oh, god.
He didn't jump before!
Dang!
I fumbled the jump!
No!
Oh, please!
Wait!
But that...
I'm learning, though!
I'm learning!
Oh, please.
Okay.
That's...
Guys!
Guys, I downloaded it.
I think I've dow...
Guys, I've downloaded it for real this time.
I am learning.
I am learning so much!
Thank you!
Everybody's like, please Doki, please just break the Monkey King from the rock already.
No, this is more important.
I need to teach a child a lesson.
I need to make sure that baby never graduates kindergarten.
That is my only purpose in life.
Literally my only purpose in life is this baby to never find love.
You can never find love, baby.
Ow.
Oh, please.
No, I'm messing it up.
Oh, God.
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, nice.
No, not nice.
Okay.
Come on.
Alright.
Nice.
No!
The double
makes up!
The fucking makes up!
Yes!
Alright, we all know that was not the run.
I fucked up the wolf power.
I actually fucked up.
Okay.
It's okay.
I'm doing less spam dodges now.
I'm locked in.
This is the run.
I'm spamming less.
That's when you know I'm locked in.
Okay.
That's good.
We're smart.
It's gonna be like overpowered as hell by the time I get there.
Okay.
Let's see.
Alright.
The Read House does support himself with a stack avoiding ground attacks.
Wait!
Maybe this is it!
Wait.
This is it?
Maybe this is it!
This is all I need to do!
I fucked up.
Ah, fuck.
Wait, what?
Oh shit!
Okay, yeah, maybe that is what I do.
Okay.
That's fucking right.
That's fucking right!
Okay.
That's fucking right.
Oh shit!
Okay.
Oh, okay.
That's very unlucky for Wolfman.
Oh fuck, okay.
It's alright.
I figured it out though.
That's fucking right!
Wait, I think I figured it out!
Okay, we gotta regen.
Wait, I think I figured it out.
I think I figured it out, guys.
No!
Oh god.
No.
Please.
No, he smacked me.
Holy shit!
I think I figured it out though!
I think I figured it out!
Oh!
I thought that was a ground move!
I was like, I'm up here!
You can't get me!
I legit thought I was...
I thought I was... I thought I was in the air!
He literally... The game literally was like, Whoa, when you're in the air...
When you're in the air...
You don't have to worry about...
When you're in the air!
You won't get hit by ground attacks!
It didn't work that you swung.
How was I supposed to know I swung my...
I just thought I was in the air!
I thought I was... I made it!
Hello.
No, you're supposed to get closer.
Oh thank god.
Okay.
It's fine.
We're fine.
Oh god.
It's fine.
We're fine.
And then dash!
Oh, this is not fine now.
Alright.
We're fine.
That's fucking right.
Oh, he swung!
Okay,
that's fine.
And then...
Oh shit, okay.
Swing!
No!
I thought I timed it correctly!
Okay.
We're fine.
Boom!
That's fucking right, baby!
That's fucking right!
Nobody loves you!
Where are your parents?!
Oh, you don't have one!
Boom!
Oh shit.
I'm so sorry.
Boom!
Oh shit!
What?!
No!
I timed it!
The very first time I ever timed it!
Oh no.
Please.
And then a flash-tag comes unexpectedly!
It always shows up when I least expect it!
Why does it always show up when I least get over it?
I'm so angry.
Oh no, my one HP.
I don't care.
That one spec is not going to change anything.
This is it.
That was the closest I've ever been.
That was the closest.
This is it.
There's no way.
There's no fucking way.
Boom.
Okay.
All right.
That's fucking right.
Oh god.
Boom.
God.
Okay.
All right.
That's fine.
That's fucking right.
That's right.
Stay on the ground, you big baby.
What are you going to do?
Yeah?
Clap?
Nobody loves you.
Oh!
That's so... I didn't mean to.
I didn't mean to.
Oh, holy shit.
I didn't mean that!
I'm sorry.
I am so sorry.
We need some more voices.
We need to kill him if he's Fahrenheit.
I don't care.
I just want to kill him.
All right.
Here is that one.
We have to kill him if it's the last thing we do.
And we have to kill him.
We're locking it in.
I'm full focus now.
I'm so full focus.
You have no idea how focused I am.
Alright.
Okay, it's personal now.
Okay, full focus.
Chat.
Holy shit.
We have not progressed this game.
We've been stuck on this stupid ass baby.
Oh yeah, please.
Oh my god.
I just want to get this guy out of my lobby, please.
Please.
Okay, nice.
Okay.
Boom.
What?
Why does he jump?
Okay.
Oh, it's a big one.
Oh.
Okay.
Stupid fucking baby.
Stupid baby.
Are you serious?
Okay.
Come on.
Come on, you guys.
Yes.
No.
He collapsed.
Okay.
Oh, why do you have to clap?
Why do you have to clap?
Stop clapping.
It's not cool.
Okay.
What?
Who was that?
No.
No!
I activated!
He keeps clapping!
Why are we still here?
Focus!
I wasn't full focus, chat.
I'm trying to focus.
I lied.
Now I am.
Why are we still here?
Just to suffer?
Alright.
This is it.
We learned.
We are so much...
No!
I got cocky!
This is the entire game.
Okay.
I'm focused now.
There's no...
Alright, you idiot.
That's right.
You cry.
Cry more.
No!
Guys!
Oh my god!
Oh shit!
Alright.
What?
Are you...
Are you fucking kidding me?
Okay.
It's okay.
It'll be fine.
It'll be so fine.
Alright.
Dodge!
Are you... Dodge!
Alright.
Dodge, okay.
Dodge!
Alright.
Here we go.
Okay, nice.
Nice, okay.
Alright.
No!
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
Keep crying.
Keep crying, baby.
Okay.
No!
Like,
I'll hit him!
I'll pin him!
I'll break it!
I actually got...
I got too greedy!
I was gonna...
I cried and I keep being too greedy!
I was gonna try to do the monkey stance!
I wanted to do the monkey stance!
Oh my god.
No!
Alright.
This is it.
I was so fucking...
I was so fucking locked in, too!
But then I was like, hee hee monkey!
Hee hee monkey!
Why do I hee hee monkey?
I didn't have the monkey!
Why do I do this to myself?
Why did I saw hee hee monkey for me?
Britney!
I just thought it'd be funny!
I literally thought it'd...
be funny!
Okay.
Fire!
No!
Oh no!
Dash!
What?!
Okay.
Okay, nice.
No!
Come on.
Nice, okay.
No!
Dash.
Oh my god.
I fucking...
Fuck you.
I hope you'll never reincarnate and be dead forever.
Oh my god.
Can not!
What do you...
What do you mean with all guidance?
Why can't I absorb this?
Why can't I...
What do you mean?
Please!
I can't even take this!
I can't!
I wasn't even supposed to kill Big Baby!
What do you mean I can't take this?
I wasn't even supposed to kill him!
I can't even kill him!
I'm sorry, but...
I am so fucked up!
I am so fucked!
I'm too low level to absorb the loot!
I can't believe it!
Why did I do this to myself?
I killed him, but at what cost?
It doesn't even feel like I won!
He still won!
I can't even take this!
No!
Oh my god!
Down goes the baby!
After like, thank you for the akasufa.
Thank you, thank you!
Oh my god, I did all that and I said I can't even absorb the fucking baby.
Oh!
Fuck me!
Oh my god.
My hate for baby has failed me yet again.
Oh, thank you for the akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Won the battle but lost the war.
Oh my god, what are you going to do?
Fucking kill me?
I fucking killed a baby today.
You think I'm scared of you?
Oh shit, new guy.
What is this?
The wolf sentinel.
Okay.
Oh shit, what the fuck did I do?
Oh god.
I'm fucking going to stand up here.
What are you going to do?
Nothing.
Nearly nothing.
Can't do...
That's looking right.
Shoot me.
Oh wait, he shot me up here.
Robbed and my total death to baby is 14 for a grand total of 18.
Oh my god.
I think I spent so much time on the fucking baby.
Everybody else has already saved... like unlocked the monkey king and I'm still here.
Which one?
This one?
We haven't even heard him fucking talk.
Get away while I... wait, where the fuck is the...
Oh, there we go.
There's the incense.
Everyone's so far ahead.
Everyone is already so far... I can grab the armor.
Let's go.
It's making a go.
Holy shit.
Fucking father.
I can't.
Yeah, that's mine as well.
Mine is fucking well.
Alright.
Examine.
Wait, how is this like better than what I have?
Alright, let's see.
This is 14.
Oh, it is better.
Okay.
You never... you didn't even have to beat the baby, guys.
That's the best part.
We didn't have to kill the baby.
We... we didn't have to kill the baby.
You can get the baby spirit later from the keeper's shrine once you get the ability to absorb spirits.
Uhhh...
Just joking around babies.
Anton, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I could have been so high leveled by the time I fight the baby that the baby wouldn't even be difficult.
The baby wouldn't have been difficult by the time I'm at the level where I can absorb the baby.
Was it worth it?
This basically justifies my hate for babies.
This just means I was right.
Babies don't deserve anything.
Alright.
Alright, here we go.
Guys, the baby basically forced me to actually dodge.
The baby forced me to learn mechanics.
Alright, let's see.
Where do I go?
I guess I go up.
I wanna like see if there's extra loot anywhere.
Oh, there is.
Will it respawn?
No.
No, don't say that.
Did it actually respawn?
There's no f***ing way.
Did I rest?
Oh my god, I didn't rest.
Let me rest.
Oh, that would be so f***ed up.
That would actually be so f***ed up after everything I did today.
And the baby f***ing comes back.
I didn't even get a chance to absorb him.
Okay.
Alright, we find out now.
I'm gonna travel.
Alright.
I don't like how the baby's there, but okay.
Is God really that cruel?
Is he really that cruel?
We'll find out today.
Alright.
Is he back?
He's gone!
But where's the spirit?
Where did the Luke...
Where...
Where did the Luke go?
The soul is gone.
Where did the soul go?
No!
No.
Alright.
Life is a cruel joke.
Life truly is a cruel joke.
But we finally unlock Wukong and find out soon!
The baby won in the end!
In the end.
The baby won.
A person with no reincarnation.
Of course, he's god-cast.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god, what's the worst thing that can happen in my day?
Damn this soldier.
Oh my god, big, big boy.
Big wolf boy.
I fucking- Whoa!
Oh god, oh god.
Oh god, I nearly just killed the baby.
And then now I have to kill the wolf?
Can I not rest?
What the fuck does that do?
Oh shit, now I have to learn new movesets already?
I just got out of a boss fight.
Holy shit.
Can I not rest?
I have to learn a new move.
I have to learn new moves.
I have to learn new combos.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Oh god.
Shit, what the fuck?
What the fuck is this?
Oh god.
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, nice.
Oh no.
Whoa!
Oh my god!
He's so strong!
Whoaaaa!
I just got back from learning baby combos.
Now I need to learn wolf combos.
right off the bat.
Okay.
The fucking potato lied.
He said there's no going back.
There's clearly going back.
Okay.
Let's fucking get closer.
Oh!
Oh, I deserve that!
I deserve that!
Oh, I get closer.
Oh.
Wait, that's the thing?
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Yeah, I'm gonna leave.
I didn't realize I can't hold it!
I didn't realize I could fall over!
I thought I could stay on high ground forever!
I just fell!
Okay, that was... I mean, that was deserved, honestly.
Yeah, there's...
Yeah.
Yeah, I deserve that.
I 100%.
I 100% deserve that.
That's fucking right.
Wolf versus wolf!
What are you gonna do, huh?
Get down from here!
Get down!
What are you gonna do, huh?
I beat a baby!
I...
I kicked a baby!
It's time to kick a dog!
I might as well... Oh, shit!
Dogs can slap!
He's just like, alright.
What the fuck?
Okay.
Alright.
I can't believe it!
I am gonna kick a puppy!
Oh!
Shit!
Okay.
That's fucking right!
That's right!
Slap in your head!
You mean nothing to me!
You mean nothing!
Your existence don't matter!
Oh!
That's fucking right!
Will anybody stop her?
Now she's targeting puppies!
Oh my god.
Nothing can compare to the fucking baby.
Nothing can compare to the baby.
Alright.
Now I need to kick a cat.
I've already hit rock bottom.
Nothing can stop me now.
Alright.
Let's see.
Enable sprinting while charging.
I feel like I might need that.
What the fuck is the pillar says?
Do I have to swap it?
How do I get out of the pillar stance?
Like...
I don't wanna be in this stance anymore.
Oh my god.
Let's see.
Oh!
Z!
Okay.
Z.
Alright.
Nah, fuck it.
Actually, no.
This actually... This stance fucking sucks.
Gonna grab this.
And then... Oh!
What's this?
From one... Okay.
Yeah.
Actually, we need that.
Okay.
We awakened it.
That's good.
Okay.
Uh...
Fucking hell.
I wanna extend that.
And then... Let's get HP.
I don't have it anymore?
Oh, there we go.
Let's get some HP.
Oh...
Oh my god.
Everything feels so much easier now.
And now that I can run while doing this, that's a lot easier.
Guys, now you know, guys.
Now you know you can skip the baby.
You're welcome.
You're fucking welcome.
I figured it out for you guys.
Alright.
Someone's like, I already fought the baby though, Toki.
I already...
I already fought the baby.
Alright.
Let's see.
I have nothing I wanna buy.
Is there anything I missed in there?
Oh, there it is.
I did it.
I got this...
The Lotus Pill.
But I got in the richest land that...
Oh, I can increase my maximum HP.
Let's go.
God, if only I had that earlier.
It's like if I fucking fought the horse guy in Elden Ring.
This is basically it.
Alright.
Like...
I've already like progressed so much.
None of these matter anymore.
What?
None of these.
None of them can hurt me.
You can't hurt me.
You can't hurt me no more.
That's fucking right.
Run!
RUN!
I already beat the game.
Alright.
Get over here.
Yeah, that's right.
Do I go this way?
Oh.
What are you?
That's fucking right.
You don't hurt me anymore.
You don't scare me.
All of you guys are weak ass.
You're like, you're like infants.
You're like in the womb for me.
Alright, nice.
What did I get?
Yarn.
You're basically, you're in the womb at this point.
I fought the real monster.
Where the fuck do I go?
Is that Fry?
Oh.
Oh god.
No poison.
Oh, that's the poison!
Okay.
Okay, by exploding, I can die.
I can get poison.
There we go.
And then I dodge.
Nice.
Alright.
I just need to find a cat.
And I will truly hit rock bottom.
Alright.
I just need to punch a cat and then we've done it.
We've got the trifecta.
All right.
Oh, what's this?
That's a real frog.
Wait, what separates you and the other frog?
Nice.
Oh, I guess that's just the area to get more willpower.
I guess that was it.
Oh, we go this way.
We're still in the prologue, guys.
We're still in cha...
Oh my god, I've been here for so long, they sent out...
Look out the magical wisp.
The magical fairy that guided me to the actual area that I should be going to.
It took me too long.
I mean there's something in this hole?
No?
Alright.
Oh no, it's the crow.
You don't scare me, crow.
I've already been...
Okay, maybe a little bit.
You might scare me a little bit, never mind.
Alright, nice.
We're fine.
Everything's fine.
I'll rest.
Will the crow come back if I rest?
Well, time to find out.
Hello?
Oh no, okay, he's dead forever.
Oh, that's what I like to see.
Okay, where the fuck do I go?
There's like so many areas to go.
Alright.
I guess we'll break some jars for some willpower.
Okay.
Huh?
Is it...
Is it Sifu?
Oh my god.
Is it him?
Is it the priest?
Who is that?
Who are you?
Have you seen those...
No, that's not him.
...souls adrift on your path?
He's got the long ears.
...never to fade.
Shame.
Your gourd serves little purpose, and mine answers solely to me.
I know a way to guide the souls, mend their paths, and set them free.
It will aid you.
Huh?
Is he gonna increase my gourd?
Oh, thank god.
Where were you earlier?
Now,
this is better.
This gourd.
Though humble, may save the lost, banish their obsessions, and guide them.
Yay!
I have more HP!
I can get more drunk now!
Under the guidance of a wise master, the destined one has mastered the art...
Oh my god.
Now I can absorb.
The gourd possesses remarkable divine capabilities.
Allowing it to absorb the lingering will of spirits.
For one as destined as you, we are like tumbleweeds.
Drifting through life.
We have left them beyond our grasp.
Alright.
How do I absorb him?
Now we can eat the baby's soul.
Will it be there?
Did I?
Oh, thank god!
Oh, thank god.
What do I do with the baby?
Now what?
Now I have the baby in me.
What do I do with it?
Oh, thank god.
I don't have to kill him again.
We ate the baby.
Master, I got the baby inside me now.
Baby acquired.
Wait, but what does the baby do?
I just absorbed him.
What does he do?
What the fuck does the baby...
What does the baby do?
Like...
Is it this?
Oh!
Okay.
Take the form of the wandering white bow with bow with almost devotion and ram the foe with your bronze skull.
Oh shit.
Wait, what?
I can be the baby?
Oh my god!
Wait, I can be the baby.
Okay, cultivate.
Oh my god, it's over.
It's time to be big baby time.
It's big baby time.
Okay, but how do I...?
I already forgot how to do it.
I already forgot.
I was like, I can be the baby.
But then like, how do I become the baby?
How do I become the baby?
The baby.
Is it a spell?
Is it?
Okay, it said spell.
Nope, that's just... nope.
Oh, it's F!
Oh my god, it's F!
You guys can't see it, I was covering it.
It's time.
What the f***?
Wait, what are you?
What the f***?!
No!
Okay, I was not paying attention.
I was trying to figure out how to be the baby.
Oh no, I'm poisoned.
Wait!
Oh, it's like re... I can't even use the... okay.
Alright.
Okay, here we go.
That's f***ing right.
Boom!
Alright.
What the f*** was that?
Is that a dragon?
Oh, it's a snake patrol there.
Okay.
We killed... we killed a snake.
I'm still poisoned though.
F*** your horn.
Where's E?
Oh!
Not!
Not good person!
Okay.
That's f***ing right.
That's right!
Can't do anything now!
Oh, s***!
Okay, maybe you can.
You know what?
Who cares?
Oh wait, maybe I do care.
Alright.
I'm gonna heal real fast.
You don't scare me.
Boom!
Oh!
That was bait.
You still don't scare me.
It takes forever to charge the baby meter.
Why?
I mean, the baby meter is so f***ing low.
Alright.
I cannot become the baby yet, guys.
I need to wait 20... I need to wait 9 months to become the baby.
Oh, s***!
Where do I go?
What?
What's that?
Oh.
You come down here.
Thank you.
Thank God they came down here.
Thank God.
I did not want to go down up there.
Nice.
Alright.
We got more gold.
Okay.
I guess I'll go this way first.
So much in this world.
Okay.
Nice.
I can assume those who had...
Oh my God.
I hate having... I hate being given free will to decide where to go.
I don't like that.
I like to be told where to go.
I like to look at maps.
You give me too much responsibility.
I don't like responsibility.
Alright.
Nice.
Oh, s***!
What?
Oh!
Okay.
That's f***ing right.
Dog!
Got that dog in me!
Oh.
Nice.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh, this song is so sick.
The song was so sick.
I got distracted.
Holy f*** the butt.
He used his butt to attack me.
That's f***.
That's f***ing right.
Oh, we did it.
Does he explode?
Oh, he just...
Oh my God.
We'll get a frog in me too.
That's right.
I punched a frog.
Oh.
I got the frog in me now.
Somebody stopped her.
Now she punched a frog?
Get down.
Nice.
Alright.
Must be like loot here, right?
After everything I did.
Or does he just live here?
Alright.
That's my home now.
He's dead so I can legally live here now.
You need the mark.
I need the yellow paint.
Somebody hold a funeral.
Frogbird's dead.
Now I have a sword, Frogbird.
Now he's inside.
Alright.
Let's see.
Oh, here.
Mushrooms.
Snakehead mushrooms.
Honestly, I do feel like a better player ever since.
I actually do feel like a better player.
The baby was literally like learning the entire fucking mechanics of this game.
Alright.
Nice.
Yeah.
I was forced to learn.
If I didn't fight the baby, I would have never learned.
Okay.
Get rid of him first.
That's fucking right.
I'm gonna charge it up.
Oh, what the fuck?
That wasn't supposed to kill you?
That's right.
What you gonna do with that sword, bitch?
Bro, there's so...
Oh, fuck.
It's a dragon.
Snake.
Snake dragon.
Oh, that's not what I wanted to do.
I just stared at him.
Whoops.
Alright.
You will be dead soon.
Don't worry.
Boom.
There you go.
Holy shit.
And I'm still in chapter one.
Oh, no.
Not the mimic.
It's fine.
Okay, that did barely anything.
That is not fine, actually.
That is not fine.
I barely did anything.
Alright.
So, I still have, like, another charged attack.
I'll hit mine first.
Nice.
Alright.
We got the snake head mushroom.
The funglings.
Oh, we got the last of us.
Where the fuck am I?
How did I get here?
How did I...
How did I get in here?
Where am I?
I can be baby!
That's it.
Come on!
I took 20!
I just need you guys to know.
It took me so long to charge that up.
And it...
I didn't even kill him.
I...
Oh, no.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Like...
That was it?
Are you fucking?
Oh, my god.
I can't believe that is all it did.
And so.
Okay, I did a circle.
Oh.
Oh, my god.
It literally, it was just 1 second.
That is so...
It took so long to charge and it only lasted a second.
That's so fucked, man.
Okay, I'll charge this.
Boom!
There you go.
Oh, the baby cameo.
Sorry, each baby cameo costs like an akasupa.
Oh, god.
And like, I don't have any mana, too.
It's a very expensive...
The cameo was very expensive, guys.
Whoa!
Oh, I used it all up.
What the fuck?!
Okay, that's fucked up.
Alright, nice.
Jesus Christ, at least I don't take that much damage.
Alright.
I'm lost.
I feel like I've been going around in circles for like...
So long.
This way?
I'm so lost.
No, this is where I...
Where am I?
Where the fuck am I?
Where?
I'm like killing everybody because I don't know where to go.
Okay.
Do they...
Do they just keep coming?
Oh, thank...
Okay, fire.
Fire!
Oh, thank god, fire.
I found fire.
Fire.
Oh, thank god, fire.
I found fire.
I know.
This humble one's name is Grongmo.
Should my demise come by your hands, please pass this message to my mind.
Where's my GPS?
Searching for deity, mortals do aspire.
Craving immortality, Yaoguai's surely will conspire.
Wait, am I fighting you?
Oh, no!
No!
Please!
This is so fun!
I have nothing!
Nothing!
I don't even have the baby!
Oh god, I don't... I don't know what you do!
Okay, oh he has like poison skills too.
Okay, that's fucking right.
Fire!
Fire beats water!
Fire beats wind!
Guys, I don't think fire beats wind.
But I will make it so!
Oh god.
Fire must be wind, right?
No way!
I don't even know your moveset!
There's no way!
Oh!
Oh god!
No!
The poison!
I had zero heals!
You fucker!
I had no heals and zero mana!
I couldn't even freeze him!
Oh my god, I left the kill so far!
Okay, we know the pathway though.
We know the pathway.
It's fine.
I know how to deal with this fucker.
We know the pathway.
It's fine.
I know how to deal with this fucker.
Oh my god, why is- Oh my god!
You fucker.
You actual fucker.
Ugh...
I can't believe I have to run so far.
I can't believe it.
I already have to use my 1H.
Oh my god, where am I?
I actually don't remember how to get there.
I- I lied.
I lied.
How am I still fucking poisoned?
How do I get unpoisoned?
What?
Where's fire?
Oh, there it is.
Alright, fuck it.
Fuck you.
I hate him so much.
Shit.
This actually...
Fuck.
I can't believe the baby whiff.
Oh my god.
The baby actually whiffed.
Jesus Christ.
Goddamn fucking baby.
Baby, man.
Okay.
Oh god.
Okay, nice.
Nice.
Goodbye.
Oh, get outta here.
Get outta here.
I don't need to be the shit on you.
Get in my body.
Get inside.
I absorb you now.
Into the Pokeball you go.
I'm so mad.
The payout for his fucking move was not worth it.
I am...
I am just so mad.
It just wasn't worth it.
Not all...
Not all of China will know I killed him.
Let's go.
I'll never get over it.
I felt like I lost a part of me there.
I have an ominous feat.
After the bell rang it seems as though the resentment in the depths of the mountain is great.
They were evil fucking gods anyway.
I did a good thing.
Alright.
The fuck?
Okay, I ran this way.
Which way did I come from?
Is it this way?
Okay, this is the way I have to go.
Alright, up the mountain.
Up should be where Oh, nice.
The incense is here.
Nice.
Alright.
Let's see what the other guys do.
Do I have new craft armor?
No.
Okay, the same armor.
I like how I paid to win and the armor literally only lasted me for like one boss.
Like, I...
I just don't know anymore.
I...
It literally just like lasted me one fucking boss as an alien.
Alright, let's see.
Who do I want?
Okay.
Sort by... Alright, so takes the form bow with outmost and with your bronze dealing massive damage.
Through a soft, the snakes will slither away once their venom is depleted.
Modern increases poison damage.
Wouldn't poison damage be good?
How do I change it then?
It still says F for baby.
How do I change it?
What?
It says cultivate, but I can't change it.
Alright, what does it look like?
Equipment?
Is it equipment?
Okay.
What does this look like?
Alright.
You know what?
Fuck it.
We'll cultivate the baby.
What's the worst that could happen?
Alright, let's see.
Do I need to rest?
Not really.
I wanna... Ah, fuck it.
Let's do it.
Let's rest up.
Alright, let's see.
Equipment.
Oh, it is!
Oh, nice.
And we get the jade necklace.
Okay, so that's how you change it.
When she is full, press F to launch spirit, transforming into a powerful...
Alright.
Okay.
That's how you do it.
Alright, we'll keep the baby for now.
Alright, how many... I have three.
I do... I think I like smash dance a lot more.
Allows the destined one to execute...
The destined one can see through the incoming nullify.
Enemies I've been seeing through are easier to stagger.
Alright, we'll try that.
Can't be that bad.
Alright.
I like to increase my damage.
And then...
Alright, I like to increase that too.
Alright.
I don't know what I'm doing.
I do not know what I'm doing.
I hope I'm doing the right thing.
Let's see.
Truly a gamer.
Oh!
Why are you crying?
Don't worry.
Give me a sec.
Boom!
I'll help your brother soon.
I gotta deal with this snake guy.
Boom!
Alright.
Oh, is that it?
Oh!
Monkey!
I didn't even see you.
Oh!
He's gonna invite me to his home!
But like, I wanna loot first.
Alright.
Hello, monkey!
Got more gold and yarn.
Nice.
Alright, monkey.
Why do you want me to go to your house?
Whoa!
Yoink!
That's mine now!
I love the, like, design.
Everything looks so amazing.
Like, I love the environments that they built.
Hello, what do you have to offer?
Same monkey!
There's more of us?
Oh!
You all ought to call me forefather.
But I'm just an old monkey, banished to the mortal world.
Wait!
Drunk monkey!
Why is he British?
Cause he's here to fucking drink, that's why.
Of course the monkey that's selling alcohol is British.
Oh.
Alright, each sip restores.
Ooh.
Okay, that's- I have coconut.
What?
Using the gourd morally...
Is that it?
Okay, so I have poison resistance now.
Alright.
Okay, upgrade drinks.
I don't have a wine worm.
Okay, I need to get a wine worm.
Upgrade gourds.
Oh!
Increase- Oh, I get five uses now!
Nice.
Maybe he's from Hong Kong.
He's the Hong Kong monkey.
Okay, that's good.
Alright, let's go.
What?
Okay, this way.
God damn it!
Why do you give me more than one path?
I hate choices!
Okay.
Oh, that's it?
That's literally it?
That's- Okay.
Alright.
Just for a mushroom.
Just for a fucking mushroom, I guess.
Anything here?
And make sure I'm not missing anything, too.
Oh.
I don't like that.
That usually means there's enemy.
Why is there such an open area?
That means I have to fight somebody.
I fucking knew it.
I was like, there's no way!
Why is it so open?
What happens to the potato man?
Past grip beyond our grasp.
The future we may still clasp.
Oh!
Where are you?
Oh, no!
Late is the hour, young one.
In which you choose to stay in my tranquil abode.
Pray tell.
To what end do you seek?
Guys.
His pull's longer than my pull.
That's fucking right.
Baby time!
And then!
Wealth time!
That's fucking right!
I'm gonna use as many abilities as I can!
Boom!
Ow.
Oh my god.
He takes- He does so much.
Like, what the fuck?
Oh shit!
Okay.
Oh my god!
What the fuck are his- What are his- What are his combos?
Oh my
god!
It just doesn't stop!
Boom!
Oh shit!
Fuck!
Okay.
I don't know his combos.
Oh god.
Oh please!
Please have mercy!
Oh god.
Oh Jesus Christ!
What the fuck!
I couldn't even dodge that!
If you get hit once, you can't even leave!
Oh my god!
What is that?
What are those combos?
I couldn't even get away!
Oh my.
Which way is the right way?
I already forgot!
Where did I come- This way.
Okay.
Alright.
Down.
Yeah.
Okay.
Alright, it's all the way down here.
Holy fuck.
Okay, I figured out how to use the baby.
Alright.
It's just looking at me.
Menacingly.
Holy shit, his combos are insane!
Oh.
That's fucking right.
Baby time!
Bam!
Did I hit it?
Oh, thank god.
Oh!
Holy fucking hell, man.
Alright, nice.
Oh, not nice.
Oh, god.
Boom!
Okay.
Okay, I can still use my combo.
Oh, shit!
Nevermind!
Oh, god!
I go first!
Nice!
Oh!
Okay.
That's fucking right.
I move first!
Move!
That's fucking right!
You're not the baby!
You're not a baby!
Oh!
So fucking easy.
Wait, phase two?
Wait a minute!
There was never a phase two!
What do you mean there's a phase two?
What do you fucking mean?
Oh, god.
Okay.
Oh, shit!
Alright.
This is fucked.
This is so fucked!
Bro!
Okay.
Oh, my god.
Why is there a phase two?
Oh!
Bro!
I can't sum it up!
Baby!
Okay.
Alright.
Oh, shit!
That's fine.
Heavy attack!
Boom!
Guys, I don't think I'm gonna be phase two.
I...
Holy shit!
What is that move?
Oh!
Oh, god.
Okay.
Alright.
We're fine.
No, we're not fine!
I don't feel okay!
What is he doing?
Oh, my god.
Okay.
Okay, I figured it out, guys.
Alright, now that I know he has a phase two...
I'll be less cocky.
Less cocky.
Wait, he can heal?
That's not very Souls-like of you.
That's absolutely fucked.
Wait, you have legs again?
How did you get your legs back?
Legs back, sir!
Alright.
Oh,
shit!
Oh, shit!
Okay.
Fire time.
Fire!
And...
Oh, shit.
I missed that.
Alright.
Okay.
He's fine.
We're fine.
We're so fine.
Boom!
Okay.
We gotta dodge now.
Alright.
He distracted me!
He distracted me with the pretty pole dancing!
He started pole dancing and I got confused!
Holy shit.
Here we go.
See?
He was pole dancing everywhere!
I got confused!
Oh, my god.
You can't skip it!
I have to watch him turn into a snake every time!
I mean, you already showed it to me.
It's not different.
I already saw it already.
Here.
Oh, shit!
Okay.
Alright.
Boom!
There we go.
Okay.
No!
What?!
Okay.
Oh, shit!
Oh, god.
Alright.
We dodged that.
This music is so intense!
No!
Alright.
Boom!
That's fucking right!
Alright.
Oh!
Oh, I got hit by that?!
Alright.
No!
Here.
I need to figure out his combo!
Okay.
Woo!
No!
Okay.
I need to fucking make sure.
Alright.
Dodge!
Oh, shit!
No!
Woo.
Woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah.
No, fuck!
Okay, I fucked up there.
I don't think guys, I don't know if I'm gonna beat this.
No!
Yes!
We did it!
Please not a phase 3.
But you got your, you got your legs again.
I defeated you, now you have to be loyal to me.
Let me absorb you.
I will never use you more than baby, but like, let me absorb you.
Wait, you're not supposed to disappear.
How else will I absorb you inside me?
What?
Have you seen them all?
No!
Do you too desire that which they ceaselessly, oh dear...
The bells?
Some bells were set in the mountains since the Black-Wind Guia's return, yet no one is allowed to near the wings.
Oh?
Maybe the bells have something to do with
Well, but what about the other bells I rang?
But I rang all the other bells too.
I assume I have to go this way?
I don't like there's no incense.
Okay, there's the cave.
Alright.
Oh, I'm like barely holding on right now.
Okay, more willpower.
Oh!
There's no monster.
There's no peek-a-boo monster.
Oh, there he is.
There he is.
Wait, then where does this go?
At least it's not peek-a-boo, okay?
He was there to show me that he's like, I'm here.
Maybe this way?
There has to be like extra stuff somewhere.
What is over here then?
Oh?
Romero, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh.
What is here?
This is not fair.
Both time.
Boom.
Look, I am nearly one HP.
I need to pick what I can get.
But happy birthday, Romero.
Oh, there it is.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Romero.
Yeah!
I don't think this is what you want to see on your birthday.
It's got a little bit dark seeing happy birthday while that was hanging in the background.
The three bears!
I did it!
What's going to happen now?
Obsession.
A remnant of worldly ties transforms the unfinished aspiration into spaces both tangible and ethereal.
Real and illusionary.
Through certain objects, one can navigate these spaces, engaging with the past and future.
Okay.
Okay, I'm back here.
What about the cave?
Wait, what?
Wait!
What about the cave?
I didn't go in the cave!
I...
Oh thank god I have HP though.
Oh wait, what about the cave?
Wait, I'm back here.
What?
Am I in the past?
Okay, I can craft... I can craft weapons!
What do I have?
Okay, this one is less strong.
Alright.
But I do have better armor now?
I do!
Alright.
I'll just... I'll just craft better armor.
Yes.
Uhh... yes.
And then... yes.
Ooh, my toes.
Alright.
Oh god, I need to clip my nails.
Did you see that?
Damn.
Alright.
I mean, it's less attack, so...
I don't really want to deal with that.
Do I have like...
Can I cultivate this more?
Wait, no I can't.
Baby is...
I need to kill more iron bulls for it.
I don't want to cultivate these because I'm not going to use it anyway.
So...
Uhh...
I don't think I'm going to get... find any shoes, guys.
I don't think Monkey is going to get shoes.
Is there like extra stuff?
Okay.
I have to be in the past then.
Because like, it says like...
Ring the bell is open like past and future.
So I'm in the past right now.
Or future?
I mean, it looks destroyed.
It looks like older than usual.
So maybe I'm in the future.
Okay.
I got prayer beads.
Monkey paws for free?
Alright.
Stone spirits.
Okay.
Nice.
One more willpower.
Alright.
Okay.
It's time to go up.
I think I got like...
The beads.
Isn't it?
Oh wait.
What?
Where were the beads then?
Wait.
Stronger.
Uh...
Modern creases.
Wait.
This is better.
Oh, this is what I found.
Okay.
I crafted that for no fucking reason, I guess.
This is better.
Oh shit.
What?
Okay.
But more damage though.
Ooh.
Wait.
This looks sick.
I don't...
Hmm.
I thought I was using...
Scored while sprinting.
Which has saved me.
Quite a lot.
But the defense though.
I don't know.
But more damage.
I like the damage part.
But the damage though.
It's unga bunga.
There's baby too?
There's...
Oh.
Wow!
We got a refa.
There's no babies too...
There's baby too?
There's baby too.
I saw baby too?
Baby you're back!
There's not baby too!
There's baby SO!
Nooo!
Baby brought friends!
Oh shit!
Baby brought so many friends!
Please, start crying baby!
Oh shit!
Boom!
These did not baby too!
My god!
Oh my god!
Boom!
Baby on baby violence!
Baby on...
I can't believe it.
Oh my god, baby too has... what is baby too doing?
What is that?
What?
What the fuck is he doing?
He's going super insane!
I don't know what baby is doing!
Oh god!
He's believing!
No!
Stop believing baby!
Oh god!
Okay.
Oh god, not baby too.
I'm so sad I have to deal with poor baby.
What is he doing?
Oh, I can heal!
What the fuck!
I can heal!
Why didn't I get that before?
This is not fair!
Blue baby never let me heal!
Holy shit!
Blue baby didn't let me heal!
Okay.
Oh god, okay.
Nice!
Oh no, reversal.
Let her do it herself.
Oh...
Hundred and seventy years spent.
Holy shit.
I truly was a carygeric.
That's fucking right.
I swear to god if there's baby 3 I swear to fucking god I'm gonna find the source of all these babies.
And you stop the source.
Gotta find the mom!
I need to find the mother.
I swear if there's baby three, I swear to fucking god.
Baby three, that's red.
I did it.
I'm back.
Alright.
That baby really did not like me.
Oh.
Goodbye.
How long was he hanging there for?
Let everything else burn.
I care for nothing but my master.
Give it to me quickly.
Oh?
Yeah.
I did it.
I let him down.
Cassandra, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay.
Now I can go up the cave.
Alright.
I have a T-control, but I have no idea what that is.
For now.
To be fair, I have no idea what I'm doing for my upgrades.
But I think I'm doing pretty well for not knowing what the fuck I'm upgrading.
Hahaha.
You know what?
Let's get the critical.
And then... I have not used the defensive thing yet.
It's just not... There's just no reason to.
Alright.
Let's grab the... already awakened that.
We'll get better dodge, I feel like.
And then better stamina.
Alright.
Oh, I should have got that.
God damn it.
Alright.
Here we go.
I upgraded... I should have upgraded the other one.
Not the sprinting shit.
I think I'm doing pretty good with my upgrades.
I have no idea what I'm doing.
But I think I'm doing pretty good.
I haven't used any of my items.
Because I'm too scared to use my items.
Because I'm hoarding my items right now.
I'm too scared to use it.
Has she died?
Nope.
Not even once.
Right, chat?
Boom.
Guys, I haven't died once.
Right, guys?
Tell him I haven't died once.
Oh, shit.
Where is he?
Nope.
Zero death run.
Right here.
I guess this is...
This has to be Lu.
Yeah.
You died?
Exactly.
Zero death run.
Oh, time to meditate.
I killed two babies today.
But yet...
Why have I not yet feel enlightenment?
Do I have to kill a third baby?
Maybe even four?
How many more babies must die?
Before I can feel something in my soul.
Alright, meditation over.
Alright.
Yay.
Celestial Taiyi Pill.
A miraculous pill crafted by King Father on...
Oh, increases maximum mana.
God, I need that, actually.
I need more mushrooms.
Alright.
Let's see.
I think I need...
I will upgrade the sprint here.
This one.
To increase my stamina rate.
Now I don't know what to do after that.
I...
Now I don't know what else to upgrade.
Alright.
Not gonna lie, I really like this game so far.
I...
So far, this game has been really, really fun.
Alright.
Let's go.
Get over here.
And there is no, like, difficulty setting.
So, like, I'm playing as it's intended.
Boom.
Yeah.
Alright, nice.
Should have practiced more.
Yeah, maybe you should have.
Wait, who's that?
Alright.
Get over here.
That's right.
You should have practiced too, bitch.
You know what?
Fuck you.
Let's freeze you.
I don't even care.
Oh, wait.
I don't regen mana.
Maybe I should have.
Okay.
Fuck.
I don't know how to get back mana, so I still don't know.
I guess I have to use my items?
I don't wanna use my items.
But my mana doesn't regenerate.
What's that?
Why is it vibrating?
Is it, like, the sauna?
Hello, sirs.
Give me a sec.
Boom.
Oh, you are weak as fuck.
Oh, fuck.
I'm sorry.
Not you.
I didn't mean you.
I meant your brother.
That I'm getting killed.
That's right.
You were weak as fuck too.
Let's see.
Don't you crowd?
Yeah, but like...
What if I need it later?
In game?
Yeah, what if we need it later in Wukong 2?
You know...
Guys.
What if I need to use it in Wukong 2, guys?
You don't understand.
Oh, shit.
Burn resistance.
Feels additional damage to the enemy upon crashing.
Oh, I like that.
I want that.
Yes.
Oh, now I'm broke.
Deals additional damage.
God damn it.
I'm broke.
Okay.
Wait.
Can I buy silk?
I can buy silk.
I forgot.
Yarn.
No, I cannot.
Never mind.
Who the fuck has silk?
Who do I need to kill to have silk?
This feels like you'll fight a fire.
Yeah, I know.
I can tell.
Who do I have to kill?
God damn it.
Okay, clearly we don't have enough for it yet.
Weapons?
Do I have enough for it?
No, it's still the wooden...
Alright.
I need to find some silk, guys.
I need to kill some spiders, some silkworms.
Alright.
Do I need silk here?
Silkworms?
Oh, hey there, big boy!
When am I gonna meet my...
my master?
Like, Sifu.
Black Wind King.
When will I meet the pig guy?
And the other guy?
I don't care as much.
All those monks consumed by the fire.
Wait, he said fire.
Roaming in Black Wind Mountain.
Thanos?
It was I who granted them eternal repose.
I have even restored the charred scriptures piece by piece.
Where's his neck?
But oh yes, I always did.
One day you shall return.
Now I'm just like, who the fuck are you?
That's fucking right.
Baby.
Oh god, I...
Like, what is he?
Is he...
What the fuck?
Where is he?
How do I feel?
How do I fight the wind?
It's not fair.
He's literally wind.
Oh shit.
Okay.
This is not fair.
He's literally fucking wind.
How do you fight the wind?
Okay.
Alright, there we go.
Alright.
Let's see.
Oh god.
He's the wind.
No.
I'm gonna punch the wind.
Oh shit, not now though.
I'll punch him.
Oh fuck.
I'm gonna punch the wind now.
I'm gonna punch the wind.
I lied about all the other times, but this time I'm gonna punch the wind.
Wait.
Where did he go?
Oh my god.
Where did the wind go?
Okay.
Alright.
The wind is so strong.
Oh no.
Not more wind.
No.
I don't know how to deal with wind.
Alright.
Guys.
Why is the wind so...
Why can't you kill...
stab the wind?
He's an airbender.
Quick.
Somebody get a vacuum cleaner.
Holy shit.
Somebody fucking grab a vacuum cleaner and stop this man.
Why so eager to die?
Let's go through right.
Baby.
Oh no.
Okay.
Nice.
No.
Okay.
Alright.
Wolf time.
Oh I fucked it up.
Oh shit.
Wind doesn't have fire?
What the fuck did I do?
What is this?
Okay.
Fuck!
Alright.
Nice.
It's okay.
Okay.
Oh no.
Not the wind.
Okay.
Nice.
Alright.
Come on.
Wait.
He can heal too?
That's fucked man.
That's actually fucked.
Like...
I'm already a monkey.
And you're just gonna...
Oh shit.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh fuck.
Okay.
Oh!
This is so fucked man.
Bro I'm already a monkey.
I'm already at a disadvantage.
Oh no!
No!
That's not fair.
It's...
It's not fair.
Holy shit.
I don't know how to fucking punch the... kill the wind.
Why can't I just breathe him in?
Yes.
Yes I am.
Yes!
Oh god.
Okay.
Oh no.
That's fucking right.
Stab!
Wind stab!
Okay.
Alright.
Nice.
Oh god.
Oh shit.
Wind stab!
Let me see.
Whoa!
No!
Fuck!
Okay.
No no no no no no no no.
What the...
What is this?
Okay.
Black wind.
No!
Not the black wind!
Okay.
Alright.
Let's go.
Let's go!
No!
Okay.
Oh shit no.
Oh please!
Oh god.
Oh shit fire!
I only have one heals left.
Alright.
Okay.
Woo!
Oh god.
Is it wind time?
Where is he?
No!
Oh god!
This is not fair!
No!
He has so many attacks!
Do you still think you are better than us?
No I don't!
Please!
I actually don't!
I don't think!
I don't think so!
I'm just monkey!
I'm just trying to find some bananas!
Please!
I don't!
No!
We were so close!
Oh shit!
Please!
I was just trying to find some bananas!
I'm not here for this!
Holy shit!
Oh my god!
This guy is so difficult!
Boom!
Okay!
Who are you to stand against me?
Nice!
Woah!
Boom!
Fire!
Oh god!
Come on!
Shit!
Okay!
There's too many!
Fire!
Wind!
Everything!
Oh god!
Okay!
I am the Black Wind!
Alright!
Wind time!
Wind gun!
Wind!
Right!
Oh!
Get over here!
Oh no!
I lied!
No I didn't!
I was joking!
Don't get over here!
I was also joking!
Please don't get over here!
Oh shit!
I didn't mean it!
I'm sorry!
Oh god!
I didn't mean it!
Oh shit!
Oh fuck!
Bro please!
Please!
Let me live!
This is definitely the worst I've ever done!
Jesus Christ!
Oh!
Okay!
Holy fuck!
The beginning worked really well!
The beginning was pretty good!
And then everything went downhill!
Everything went fucking downhill man!
Jesus Christ!
Do I have any upgrades?
No!
Okay!
Alright!
What do I have in my inventory?
Okay!
I have...
Upon use considerably increased stamina!
I think it's time!
Guys!
Alright!
I think...
No I don't need it!
No!
What if I use it and then I die?
Guys!
Maybe you're right!
I feel like I'm gonna use it and then I'm gonna die!
That's fucking right!
Okay!
Is he gonna fly?
Boom!
I don't know what this does!
But like I have some...
I used something!
What is tea?
I don't know what tea is!
I've ruined everything!
What did I activate?
I don't know!
I actually don't know what I activated!
It's just the tea!
Oh no!
Oh god!
Oh fuck!
Okay!
It's not fair!
She's drinking too!
Alright!
Okay!
It's just a drink!
That's cool!
Oh!
Okay!
Boom!
I don't know what I...
Oh shit!
Oh god!
Okay!
What?
That's actually not fair!
That's not fair!
You're supposed to be frozen!
Okay!
Oh god!
Oh!
You can't freeze the wind!
What do you mean?
You're literally the wind!
What do you fucking mean?
You're literally the fucking wind!
And I'm the cheap trick?
You turn into wind!
I'm just a monkey!
I'm just the monkey!
The spell he just cast The spell he just cast may appear intricate The spell he just cast may appear intricate But it's not hard to learn Are you sure?
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
But what he left here But what he left here could surely help us He probably left
I don't feel so lucky, man.
What did I get?
What?
Cloud step.
I'm the wind!
What you gonna do now that I'm the wind?
Nothing can stop me now.
Now I am the wind.
I'm the wind now, bitch.
Oh my god, I feel so powerful now.
I feel so strong.
Wait, there's a jar.
Open the jar.
Materials.
Oh!
That upgrades my staff?
I didn't think.
That's right.
Nothing can stop me now that I'm the wind.
Alright, let's see.
Let's hope nobody brings a vacuum.
Oh, fucking hell.
That shit was so stressful.
I'm so happy he did not have a phase 2.
I'm so fucking happy.
Alright.
We go this way.
Go to somebody's...
Let's just upgrade.
Let's just cool down a little bit and upgrade some... We have enough for one upgrade.
Okay.
Spells.
Alright, what does this do?
Increases each talent level.
It considerably increases the maximum health of the decoy.
Oh, he's gonna hit.
Oh, it distracts him.
Okay.
Oh!
I'm gonna grab this.
Cause like, when I'm out of it, then I have like a stronger attack.
Right?
I assume that's what it is.
Why do I need to like sidestep?
There's so much space.
Wukong.
You're not... Your chest is not that big.
I'm sorry, man.
You did not need to sidestep that.
Oh my god.
I got the cloning technique.
Yeah.
Yeah, he was known for that too.
Will I have the multiple wukongs though?
Do I get a new weapon?
No.
Okay.
Maybe I can...
Uh... I should be able to... Wait.
Do I have like new spells that... No, I can't.
I need iron bull.
Uh...
Craft armor.
Okay.
Do I have enough for...
No.
I still... I still haven't killed silk stuff.
God damn it.
Do I have anything?
Right?
Uh...
Set spells.
Cultivate.
Store.
Sell.
I'm just gonna rest up.
Okay.
No, I can only craft right now.
I think... I think weapon upgrades?
Uh...
Let's see.
Inventory.
Yeah, I can't do anything yet.
Oh, this is... I was like...
Some hidden vessels left by can be discovered.
Each using them costs chi, which can be recovered.
But what does it do?
Oh!
It's just burn immunity!
Okay, that was useless.
Okay.
It was literally just burn immunity.
Alright.
Movement speed.
Okay.
I think I'm gonna grab defense.
For sure.
I was like using it and I was like, what am I doing?
Like, what am I...
I'm just like...
What am I... What am I fucking doing?
Right now.
Oh, these are all the chiefs I killed.
I killed all of them.
What about the kings?
I killed two of the kings.
Oh, I killed three of the kings!
I killed the black wind king.
And then...
Yeah, alright.
Alright.
We go... this way.
Bro, these guys are like...
So easy.
Okay, that's a little embarrassing, man.
Alright.
Fucking easy.
Bro, remember when, like, they taught me to try and use the spinny pull thing and I was like, nah.
I can literally just run and dodge that shit.
Alright.
Get over here.
Wait!
That's friendly fire!
Holy shit!
Poor rat!
That's... Wait!
He's also shooting this rat, too!
Okay.
Nice.
Okay, now that I know there's friendly fire, it's...
Okay, let me get rid of this rat first.
No.
And then I'll... And then I'll deal with you.
And I'll deal with you later.
I like that there's friendly fire.
That makes me very happy.
Okay, I need to figure out...
Alright, we fight here.
Okay.
Big baby!
Big baby time!
I think the arrow killed him!
Holy shit!
Wait, the arrow actually killed him!
Wait, how do I kill you?
Wait, that's not fair!
You get to live up there!
God fucking damn it!
Alright.
I'll deal with you later.
I'm gonna loot.
I'm gonna fucking loot.
I'll deal with you.
Oh, you think you can flank me?
That's fucking right.
No, you cannot!
Bam!
Oh, I am running out of stamina, though.
Give me a sec.
Oh!
I'm gonna throw that at me!
Jesus Christ!
You're so tanky!
You're literally a tank, but no damage!
Phew!
Alright.
Yeah, you should've.
You should've put more stuff on damage, like me.
Oh, wait!
Why would I use you?
You're literally weak as hell!
The wolf assassin?
Bro, you're literally blue!
You're literally blue!
That's the weakest spirit out there.
I have purple spirits.
What the fuck am I gonna do with you?
You're gonna live in my gourd, I guess.
Alright.
Let's see.
We gotta go this way.
Now we can go fucking kill these...
God damn it!
I can't even do anything to these rats!
This is not fair!
They get to live up there forever!
...
This is not fair.
I have to deal with these guys.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, I mean, shoot him for me.
Shoot him.
At least they're shooting him for me.
Okay.
God damn it!
Oh, okay.
Thank you.
Thank you, rats!
Thank you!
Wait, can my clouds kill him?
...
Guys, you lied.
Guys.
Guys, my clouds can not kill him.
...
Oh, I guess you're invisib...
Oh, I'm so fucking stupid.
You wanted me to be cloud so I won't get hit.
Oh, I am so fucking stupid.
I was like... I just wanted to kill it.
I... I...
I just wanted to kill.
I didn't think about sneaking past it.
I... I didn't understand the concept of, like, sneaking?
Oh, shit.
What's that?
Sneaking?
Is that another form of killing?
Okay.
Oh, thank you for getting closer.
Did you run out of arrows?
Yes.
Of course I choose violence.
...
Of course!
Why would I keep them alive?
Alright, up I go.
I can't sprint.
Oh, no.
It's because it's uphill.
...
Alright, get over here.
Boom!
That's fucking right.
You're next.
...
Boom!
That's fucking right.
Don't you piss me off again, wolves.
...
Alright, upgrade time!
Upgrade time!
I feel like I should get more of these.
Increases damage reduction.
Actually, yeah, I'll get that.
I need more stuff for my stance.
Alright.
Goodbye.
Is there any items here?
What the fuck?
Why is there a little cubbyhole?
...
Oh, just because I can...
...property damage.
Nice.
There we go.
Easy.
I love property damage.
Oh, thank god.
Thank god.
...
Incense time.
I still have no silk!
I've been trying to find silk this entire time!
Where are all the silkworms?
...
I'll rest up, just in case.
Where the fuck are the silkworms?
...
We're literally...
We're literally in the birthplace of silkworms!
Oh, this is... oh.
Oh.
Alright, let's see if I can actually buy silkworms now.
I can buy yarn!
...
No, I can't!
They just have yarn!
...
They literally only have yarn!
Okay.
I can't upgrade the bait.
I don't think I can.
Can I?
Baby, can you be strong?
I can!
Baby time!
Bro, you're blue!
...
You're literally...
You don't even require anything else.
You require will to act to level up.
...
You're fucking weak!
I am not giving him a chance, chat!
Bro, he's fucking blue!
What am I gonna do with blue?
...
Alright, this seems like a boss fight.
Out of sight, out of mind is a fool's task.
Seeing but seeing through is what wise men do.
...
But didn't he turn mad?
By what he saw, too.
...
Who's this?
Bear?
...
It's time to punch a bear.
That's fucking right.
I'm ready.
I'm fucking ready to punch a bear.
That's right!
...
No animal is safe!
No animal is safe from me!
...
Holy shit!
He does not do a lot of damage, guys.
...
Haha, stupid.
Yeah, get fucking...
...
Oh shit!
I did not mean to...
...
What the fuck is that suplex?
He fucking did a suplex, guys!
...
Holy shit, he's wrestling!
This bear is wrestling!
...
Oh my god!
He's wrestling!
Oh, this is the hardest one!
...
Okay.
Holy fuck!
Oh, guys!
This is not looking too good for me right now.
...
This is not looking too good.
Bro, he's actually wrestling.
...
Oh, please let me go!
Holy shit!
...
Boom!
Smack that butt!
That's fucking right, smack you in the ass.
What you gonna do about it, huh?
Whoa, whoa, whoa, why are you standing up?
...
Whoa, whoa, whoa!
Okay, that's why!
...
Okay, I get it now.
Whoa, shit!
Fuck yeah!
Okay, now I know for sure I'm not gonna beat him.
...
Oh my god!
Bro, that bear fucking...
...
He's a fucking wrestler!
Bear's gonna hit you with a stone cold summer.
...
I think I can... wait, you're right, I can upgrade my...
...my wine.
I remember I got the upgrade for it.
I almost forgot about the upgrade.
Wait, can I?
Do I have to visit the monkey guy?
Do I have to visit the Hong Kong monkey?
...
The British Hong Kong monkey?
Where is he?
Where does he live?
I don't remember where he lives.
...
It's been so long!
Oh, there he is!
Marsha, yeah!
...
I need to upgrade my wine.
In Hong Kong!
Guys, I gotta...
...
I gotta...
I gotta fucking find...
Where is it?
Is it this way?
This way, okay.
Alright, alright, Hong Kong monkey.
I'm back.
Do you have silk?
Oh, please tell me you have silk.
Why are you so much bigger than me?
Am I an adolescent?
Oh, thank god.
Oh, I finally...
...upgraded my stuff.
Wait, do you sell silk?
No, you sell lotus seeds.
...
What do I do with that?
Like...
...
Does anyone know?
Okay, I know the game literally just came out today, but like...
...is it one time use?
...
Is that one time use?
Oh, don't?
...
I can't tell.
I'm just gonna sell my gold.
...
Is there a way to max it out?
Oh, it is?
Why would we know?
Oh, scroll wheel.
Thank god.
Alright.
At least we have more heals now.
I still don't know where the fucking silk is!
...
I'm killing everything but bugs!
Okay.
Travel.
...
Where is it?
No.
There we go.
...
Okay.
Let's fucking fight John Cena.
...
Let's fight Kuma from Tekken.
Now, I guess.
Hello.
Hello, Kuma from Tekken.
...
Baby.
Baby time!
...
Boom.
Why are you fucking running?
..
Boom.
...
Let me go.
Oh god.
...
Jesus Christ.
Alright.
I do so little damage.
Oh, fucking hell!
Oh, no, please!
I'm so sorry!
Okay.
Oh shit!
Don't suplex me, please!
How did I miss my bullet?
Oh, fuck!
Guys, I don't like fighting him.
I think he's...
He has so much HP!
He should be balanced!
Okay.
Alright.
Oh, god!
Okay.
Oh, please!
Oh!
He slapped me!
Did anyone get the license on this bear?
Oh, god.
Oh!
Not the suplex!
I didn't dodge the suplex!
Oh, god.
Oh, my god.
Oh, please!
Oh!
He's burning!
That should be illegal!
Oh, my god!
Please!
I can't see anything!
What the fuck!
I can't...
Let me go!
Let
me go!
Guys, I don't think...
Guys...
Guys, he's too strong!
This bear!
Oh, fuck!
Oh, my god!
I can't see...
He has like...
He's literally doesn't...
He takes up 20% of...
He takes up 50% of my screen!
I can't see anything!
I actually can't see anything!
Oh, god!
I'm leaving.
Oh, no!
He did it!
Guys, he didn't want me to leave.
He didn't want me to leave.
Oh, he's so tanky!
I almost had wolf powers, too!
I almost had wolf powers!
It was so close!
I mean...
It did happen...
I just couldn't use it in time.
Oh!
Goh-fucking...
If you upgrade the wolf...
You'll be able to beat him!
I am not going to...
fucking upgrade the wolf!
Guys...
Yes, we are not going to upgrade the fucking wolf sword.
Guys,
the wolf is not the answer.
I need you to know that.
The wolf is not the answer, guys.
I know it despite how much you guys think the wolf is the answer.
The wolf is not the answer.
Oh, God.
Oh, God!
Give us the wolf, Doki!
I'm not giving you guys the wolf.
Oh, God!
Oh, God, please.
Please.
Oh, God, thank God.
Nice.
Let me get another... No!
Oh, fuck!
Okay, I got the dodge.
Okay.
Oh, no, not fire.
Not fire!
No, wolf.
What's the point?
The wolf is not the answer!
That is the point!
Okay.
Okay, nice.
When is the bear coming out?
Oh, God!
Oh!
Shit!
Oh, God.
I need to reload.
Reload!
No!
What the fuck?
Holy shit!
I'm so unlucky.
I actually am.
I can't believe.
Oh, my God.
Holy shit.
How did this happen?
How did this happen to me?
I've made my mistakes.
Okay.
Oh, God.
Oh, fucking hell!
Come on.
This is not fair.
This is actually not fair.
He gets to use fire attack again?
Okay.
What?
That hits me?
Fucking bitch.
I'm sorry.
I didn't mean that.
I didn't mean it.
I'm so sorry.
I'm not sorry.
I lied.
I fucking lied.
Oh, fire.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Come on.
I don't think I... I don't think I'm gonna get this.
I don't think so.
I'm way too weak.
Oh, God.
No!
No.
I ran out of stamina.
This is bad.
This is so bad.
No!
Oh,
God.
No.
No, this is bad.
No!
He's gonna use his stupid fire attack!
Okay.
Bye.
Oh, God...
Holy shit.
I took a stupid fucking bear.
That's right.
I will fucking punch a bear, too.
I will kick a bear.
Where's your children?
I will fucking punt a cub too...
Holy shit!
Holy shit.
What do you mean you'll spare my life?
Wait, what's going on?
What the fuck happened?
What?
Oh, pardon me, young sage!
Mercy, young sage, have mercy!
That's right, peg!
I was just a pawn of the Celestial Court!
If given a choice, who dared to challenge the mighty wrecker of the Celestial Palace?
His words ring true.
No matter how daring he was, he had not the nerve to harm the great sage.
There must be someone else pulling all the strings.
Exactly!
And this thing is eerie!
I had no idea how to make use of its power!
Except to enshrine it up there, tricking lesser yaoguays into offerings!
If you pardon me, I'll go back to Guan Yin to atone for my actions and be put back on the engaging band!
You will never see me again!
I'm not out there anymore!
I know his nonsense!
Go now, little monkey.
Go and retrieve the great sage's relic!
Alright, get over here.
It's time to absorb.
Bird!
That's me!
Oh my god, what the fuck is wrong with your eyes?
Oh, guys!
It has two pupils!
That's not me.
I take it back.
Not me.
It's a freak.
What the fuck is wrong with this boy?
Okay, thank god.
I thought he killed the frog.
I thought he crushed the frog with a rock.
I choose bear.
Doki, I'll beat up a bear.
Rob, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh!
Is that the bear I beat up?
He gave the child money?
This bear fucking beat the shit out of me and he gave the child money?
Why couldn't he give me money?
He gave the child money.
That's the bear.
Rob, don't be like that.
He gave the child money.
Rob, it's my problem.
Rob, you beat up a fox.
You beat up a fox to run away from the old dog.
You did it again.
No, I don't, because you are a monkey.
I didn't know that's a monkey.
I tried to scare him and he had no mercy.
Is that Sifu?
With the power
of robes.
Oh!
It's Sifu!
Sifu!
That's him!
Bum bum.
Bum bum bum.
Oh and then he got corrupted!
And then he became the bear!
I really like this animation.
Bereft of that Kasaya.
How shall they show the world their ties are cut?
And their lust is quelled?
I finally finished chapter one.
I'm fucking fine.
Could it be so long?
And the smoke blinds.
Stumble on the lesser.
Lame.
That's one chapter!
That is so much.
With such clumsiness, what destiny do you claim?
As the small fish catches its prey...
Tutorial done.
Who is the bigger fish?
I can't see it.
As for the prey and the small fish...
They are swimming everywhere.
The carving eyes.
Okay, there's...
Okay, there's five chapters because there's five relics.
That makes sense.
I'm level 22 now.
I feel like I'm overleveled.
Because of the fucking child.
Oh!
I got...
I finally got silk, guys!
I finally...
I finally got silk.
Two whole silk, everybody.
Two whole silk.
Holy shit.
Oh.
What's this?
Yi?
In his last life, the monk was Jin Chan Tzu.
The second disciple to Buddha in the West.
Yet his arrogance led him to disregard the Dharma teachings.
And as a result, the Buddha cast him down to the mortal realm.
He was destined to face eighty wars.
He won trials throughout his journey.
The fire for that kasiya was merely...
The whole two silk were fucking rich!
Oh, there he is.
The greedy man.
That baby?
Who's this?
A mere human, blessed with a lifespan nearing three centuries.
Yet he was never sated.
He just had to seize that one kasiya.
Centuries of devotion, undone by a moment's greed.
In the end, a lost soul became him.
How pathetic.
Poor guy.
Just don't be greedy.
Oh, what's this?
A fine guardian for Guan Yin.
Am I gonna beat that guy up too?
And he came back here to daydream immortality.
Sadly, he had the greed, but lacked his followers, but not himself.
His destiny was sealed the moment he donned...
Oh, that's the bear!
That's the bear!
That's the bear, I did beat him up!
Fuck yeah, you deserve that.
That's him!
I did beat him up!
Okay.
Oh my god.
What a chapter.
Can I look at my inventory?
A glimpse reveals the foe's might.
A talent tilts to an unknown.
An unfair fight.
Hold to awaken.
Considerability increases.
Oh, I had to pick between.
The cooldown on the spell is massively reduced.
Considerability increases.
Focus gain upon consecutive.
I feel like...
Is focus mana?
Or the...
Focus is the critical...
The right click, right?
I feel like I should get the critical hit damage.
Focus is...
Yeah, I'm gonna get critical hit.
Uh...
Alright.
Alright, my little freak.
What's this?
Transformation?
Each talent level increases might recovery speed.
What is...
Is transformation the baby or the...
Uh...
Is that the baby or the...
The wolf.
Wolf?
Okay.
Um...
I'm gonna save two...
Uh...
Might recovery speed.
I might get this then.
I'm gonna grab the might recovery speed.
I don't really like cloud step.
I feel like I'd rather save it for the lock.
The lock seems like...
Stronger.
Cause like...
It takes mana away and I...
I can't waste that at all.
I feel like...
Like I don't wanna waste my mana.
Is there like any good?
Reduces...
Wait...
What do you mean?
Massively reduces stamina cost when in water?
Wait a minute...
Am I gonna be swimming?
Am I...
Wait a minute...
What is this foreshadowing right here?
Wait...
No...
What is this foreshadowing?
Let's be ready.
But I don't wanna swim.
No...
Not the water levels.
Okay.
Black Bear Gwaii.
Alright.
This is the...
Here.
Guy I killed.
Keeper of the Black Wind.
Uh...
Black Wind.
That's him.
Alright.
Let's look at the intro.
For the next one.
For the next chapter.
Yes.
Please.
Yellow sand.
That is sand!
We're back in sand land!
Right?
It's loading!
That's why I'm lagging beer.
That's why I'm fucking lagging!
I wanna see the...
The intro for chapter 2.
Guys.
I really like this game.
I think like...
You know on Saturday we were up here and it was like...
You know Saturday we're supposed to have God of War?
I think we'll swap it to Wukong.
This game has been really fun.
Now I don't know why it just got really good reviews.
Where's your head?
What the fuck?
How are you singing?
No head?
What the fuck?
He's Irish?
I like how he made him Irish.
How did I get here?
Oh wait is that Scottish?
Is he Scottish?
Yeah the fact that it was like Chinese and then he started becoming Scottish.
HAHAHAHAHA
This is so fucking weird.
He started speaking Scottish.
Alright got her.
I might have taken... oh no.
Wait a minute this is water.
Give me a sec guys.
I know you want to shoot your arrows but I'm trying to loot here.
Guys I know you really want to shoot me guys but give me a... where are these?
Are they rats?
Or are they wolves?
They're rats.
That's a giant ass rat.
Wait you're fucking weak.
Okay give me a sec bro.
Rat guy give me a sec.
That's fucking right.
What are you doing in the desert rat?
Alright.
He's a rat soldier.
Oh I'm going to be killing rats.
Rats rats rats.
We are the rats.
Alright we're going to be killing... oh no.
Oh no.
Wait the desert is worse.
I don't know... wait there's... there's so...
Where do I go?
This is... this is worse.
I'm so confused.
There's too many.
There's too many pathways.
Where do I go?
Where am I?
I'm already lost.
Where do I go?
Which is the pathway?
Am I?
Is this the... is this...
Oh there's the incense.
Okay.
Alright.
Give me a sec.
I'm going to charge up my attack.
Boom.
That's right.
Easy.
Alright.
Yeah I'm way too tired to navigate the desert.
I'm just like...
This is fucked.
I cannot...
I cannot navigate this.
We're going to call it here.
Oh my god.
That was so fun.
Oh I didn't have two streams tomorrow.
I'd play longer.
I definitely would play a lot longer if I didn't have two streams today.
Um...
Not today.
Tomorrow.
Um...
But I...
Really enjoy this game.
Not gonna lie.
I really, really like this game so far.
I think like...
Uh...
Um...
I think the reviews were definitely right when they said that the gameplay has been really fun.
And I do enjoy the character designs, the environment, the music.
And like...
Uh, the story is like, I think you have to read Journey to the West to understand the story a little bit because like, um, the story, I feel like, I think it's mostly hidden in the lore aspect, like the, the guide itself, like, um, and like, I feel like you have to have,
uh, you have to have like background knowledge of Journey to the West to sort of understand, uh, the story and, uh, like where it's heading and stuff.
Like that, because I still, like, I still don't know who the fuck I am.
Like, no, I know who I am, but like the character himself is very, like, he's like, what's going on?
Because we haven't really, we haven't really freed Wukong, like actual, we haven't got our memories back yet.
So we're like just this random monkey that's just traveling around.
Um, so like, we still haven't discovered who we really are yet.
So that's like, basically, the gist of it, because we're like, our memory, we're like, uh, we're just like traveling.
We'll be like, what the fuck?
Why are you, why are you trying to, uh, why are you trying to kill me?
I'm just a regular monkey.
But then we're all like, and then, but then all the enemies were like, you're not just a regular monkey.
You're special.
And then I'm just like, but I just want banana.
No.
Um, but yes, I'm just a lost monkey.
Uh, but yes, uh, the story itself, I think you definitely do need to know background knowledge of Journey to the West, understand what's going on and everything.
And, uh, it's been fun though.
I've been enjoying it a lot.
I think like killing that giant ass fucking baby made me a better player because I, everything else has been a lot easier now.
Like all the other enemies have been a lot easier after going through the fucking bullshit and the 200,000 moves that the blue baby had.
Um, the other enemies have like three combos.
That fucking baby had like 200,000 different combos.
He can clap.
He can jump.
He can fucking headbutt.
He has the Kamehameha.
He has the force blast.
He had everything.
It was bullshit.
That was actually bullshit.
But I hope you guys enjoy this stream tomorrow.
I will be on Twitch for a morning stream.
Uh, today, the games gone watch the long.
And then after that, we will be.
Checking out the new Overwatch update.
On Saturday, I'm going to change God of War to Wukong because I honestly really want to play Wukong.
I just really want to play Wukong.
Anyway guys, I'm going to call it here everybody.
As always everyone, thank you all for the super chats, for the follows.
Not follows, sorry, for subscribing.
I'm already on the Twitch mindset.
For subscribing, for all the gifted membership.
As always everybody, stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
If you're used to it from me, head to bed because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys!
Bye!